Herzlich willkommen zur 21. Folge von Alternativlos.
Dieses Mal ohne Gast und wir wollen heute mal ein wenig über Terrorismus reden und Terror und insbesondere auch ein wenig über Rechtsterrorismus. Und als Bonustracker gibt es am Ende eine neue Folge von El Fefe vs. Frank Guevara.
Also wir fangen wie immer ein bisschen mit dem historischen an und der Begriffsfindung. Und das ist schon der erste Punkt, der ganz interessant ist, denn Terrorismus ist eigentlich definiert als die Anwendung von Gewalt zum erreichen politischer Ziele. Und da steht wohlgemerkt nichts drin von wegen der, der die Gewalt anwendet, ist ein kleiner Einzeltäter und der wendet es gegen den großen Staat an. Und da steht auch nichts von, dass es da irgendwie um den Umsturz geht oder so, sondern das sind alles nachträglich angefügte Elemente. Denn das Hauptproblem bei Terrorismus ist, wenn man sich so die Presse anguckt, dass es immer negativ belegt wird. Das ist eigentlich keine tatsächliche Beschreibung der Strategie, sondern es ist ein Kampfbegriff, den man benutzt, um seinen politischen Gegenüber oder Gegner zu diskreditieren. Und deswegen ist es eben wichtig, eine Definition zu finden von Terrorismus, die zwar auf dessen Untaten zutrifft, aber nicht auf die eigenen Untaten. Und daher kommen diese ganzen Sachen von wegen, ja, aber es geht hier irgendwie selbstmordanschläge und so.
Ja, ursprünglich kam der Begriff ja aus der Zeit der französischen Revolution, oder?
Genau. Und zwar gab es am Anfang der französischen Revolution so eine Zeit, wo wild rumgiotiniert wurde, wo Adlige und Kontarevolutionäre eben dann mal eben hingerichtet wurden. Und das ist in Frankreich selbst und dem Ausland als Terror gesehen worden, allerdings durchaus positiv belegt. So im Sinne von jetzt haben die endlich auch mal was zu fürchten.
Es gab ja auch bei der, also nach der Revolution in Russland, gab es ja dann auch diesen, den Weißen Terror, also der von den kontarevolutionären Kräften war, der dem dann mit dem Roten Terror, also von den revolutionären Kräften, den Leinisten begegnet wurde. Und am Ende war es halt nicht besonders lustig für alle, die da irgendwie dazwischen waren. Aber da wurden halt eben solche Gewaltstrategien auch durchaus als ja offen bezeichnete Mittel der politischen Auseinandersetzung oder eben militärischen Auseinandersetzung betrieben.
Das ist ja immer so ein bisschen das Problem, dass wir eigentlich von so einer Art Krieg reden. Aber es ist kein wirklicher Krieg, denn, also was vielen gar nicht so bewusst ist, Krieg ist ja gesetzlich geregelt. Also jetzt nicht nur in unserem Strafgesetzbuch, sondern auch international gibt es ein Völkerrecht. Und das Google-Stichwort an der Stelle heißt Hager Landkriegsordnung, wie Den Haag. Und da ist geregelt worden, ein Krieg ist zwischen zwei Ländern und die bekämpfen sich mit Kompatanten. Das sind offizielle Teilnehmer in dem Krieg. Die erkennt man daran, dass sie irgendein Abzeichen oder eine Uniform tragen und dass ihre Waffen offen getragen werden. Also nicht irgendwie verdeckt unter Mantel, sondern außen. Und die beschießen sich gegenseitig. Und es gibt aber Grenzen für das Beschießen, nämlich wenn sich einer ergibt, dann darf man nicht weiter schießen, sondern man muss den Fehr behandeln und so weiter und so fort. Und man darf nicht Zivilisten beschießen. Und man darf nicht, wenn da zum Beispiel man kommt am Dorf vorbei und da liegt irgendwie ein Haufen Gold, dann darf man nicht einfach das Dorf angreifen. Sondern man darf eigentlich nur andere Kompatanten angreifen.
Hat sich da jemals jemand dran gehalten?
Ja, also das ist eine relativ spannende Sache. Denn da hat sich sogar die Nazis haben sich daran gehalten. Also ein partiell natürlich nur. Aber es gab tatsächlich große Furcht davor, dass sie dessen überführt werden könnten.
Gegen das Verstoßes dagegen.
Das Verstoßes dagegen.
Das würde dann als unrichterlich gesehen. Oder was war? Ja, also eigentlich gibt es doch keine Sanktionen, oder?
Genau, also es gibt keine Sanktionen, weil die Idee des Strafgerichtshofes, des Internationalen Strafgerichtshofes, also viel neuer als die Idee von, das überhaupt mal gesetzlich zu regeln. Und also es gibt ja diese Geschichte davon, dass die Nazis ein paar Juden vorgehalten haben, weil sie damit rechneten, dass das Rote Kreuz kommt und eine Inspektion macht.
Ja, stimmt. Die hatten diese Lager, die sie halt als Showlager quasi hatten, um zu verhindern, dass vorzeitig enttarnt wird, was sie da eigentlich tun bzw.
Also die haben sich wirklich Sorgen gemacht. Die hätten auch den Roten Kreuz sagen können.
Naja, ich glaube, es ging ihnen unter anderem darum, dass sie den anderen eine Gelegenheit zum Wegsehen geben. Also dass sie den anderen die Möglichkeit geben zu sagen, aber hier ist ja alles in Ordnung, wir haben es ja gesehen.
Also wie das jetzt konkret läuft, die Begründung, warum man das hat, ist ja letztendlich egal. Aber sie haben sich jedenfalls an die Regeln so ein bisschen gehalten.
Also sie haben so getan, als wenn sie sich an die Regeln halten.
Ja, also sie haben sich bemüht, dass es zumindest so aussieht, als würden sie sich dann halten. Also wenn man jetzt eine feindliche Stadt angreift, das war ja im Russland-Feldzug gab es diese unglaubliche Geschichte, dass sie dann mal eben eine Stadt eingenommen haben und dann haben sie so was wie 300.000 Kriegsgefangene genommen. Und da ist ja völlig klar, schon logistisch, das kann man ja völlig vergessen, die Idee, dass man also geordnet, man muss die dann verpflegen und so. Also man kann die nicht einfach irgendwo einsperren oder verrotten lassen, sondern es gibt also Regeln, dass man dann mit denen ordentlich umzugehen hat. Und man darf sie zwar für für Arbeiten heranziehen, aber lustigerweise darf man nicht Offiziere für Arbeiten heranziehen. Also man merkt, die Regeln sind so ein bisschen älter. Jedenfalls, es gibt also diese Regelung. Und da haben sich auch die Kriegsparteien so mehr oder weniger versucht, daran zu halten. Aber das stellt sich natürlich die Frage.
Also nur bis zu dem Grad, dass es halt irgendwie konvient war für sie.
Na ja, aber sie haben nicht einfach irgendwie. Also das Ziel war nicht, Stalingrad einfach wegzunuken. Wenn sie die Technologie gehabt hätten, hätten sie es vielleicht irgendwie tun können. Aber sie hätten auch so mit dem Artilleriefall einfach weiter schießen können, die Leute alle. Also nach Kriegsrecht ist es verboten, dass du einfach Zivilisten erschießt zum Beispiel, sondern du darfst nur Kompatanten erschießen.
Da haben die Nazis aber auch großflächig geplant.
Und das haben die Nazis natürlich auch, ja. Aber ich würde sagen, es gibt da noch mehr Regeln. Aber sie haben versucht, sich so ein bisschen daran zu halten, aber eben nicht an allen Stellen. Aber diese Idee, wenn du eine fette Stadt einnimmst, dass du jetzt 300.000 Kriegsgefangene hast, dass die sich überhaupt stellt und dass sie nicht einfach sagen, alle abmurksen, das ist ja auch schon mal ein Datenpunkt. Jetzt kein sonderlich großer, aber man sah die auch tatsächlich als Kriegsgefangene. So, jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was macht man denn, wenn man jetzt in irgendein Land einmarschiert und die Armee ist irgendwie nicht bereit oder wird schnell geschlagen und das Volk fängt dann an, so eine Militia zu gründen.
Partisanen.
Ja, Partisanen-Krieg zu führen, mehr oder weniger unorganisiert. Und da gibt es dann im Völkerrecht verschiedene Abstufungen davon, was man dann noch als Kombattanten wertet und was nicht. Aber ursprünglich ist die Idee der Partisanen und der Terroristen so ein bisschen vergleichbar mit, das sind, sagen wir mal, Saboteure oder Spione oder so, also feindliche Kämpfer.
Irreguliere Einheiten, quasi die.
Die aber keine Kombattanten sind und deswegen muss man sie nicht in Kriegsgefangenschaft nehmen.
Also der Ursprung davon ist halt diese komische meditärische Ehre-Dings da, also dass man halt den feindlichen Soldaten halt irgendwie noch die soldatische Ehre erweist und ihn halt irgendwie entsprechend behandelt und...
Nicht nur den Feindlichen, es geht ja auch um sowas wie dieser Terror zum Beispiel, ne? Wenn jemand, also damit, dass du Soldat bist, hast du auf der einen Seite das Privileg gewonnen, dass du erschossen werden darfst im Krieg. Du hast auf der anderen Seite aber das Privileg gewonnen, dass sie dich nicht einfach so erschießen dürfen, ja, sondern es muss eine Kriegshandlung sein. Und so ist es ja auch, wenn du als Soldat ein Deserteur wirst, dann entziehen sie dir den Status und können dich danach, also jetzt zwar nicht direkt erschießen, da muss es dann so ein Pseudo-Gerichtsverfahren geben, genau einen Standgericht geben. Aber so ähnlich ist das eben auch mit Terroristen. Also wenn jemand am Krieg teilnimmt, ohne eine Uniform oder Abzeichen zu tragen, oder wenn er seine Waffe versteckt hat oder so, dann ist das eigentlich eben kein...
Das ist halt aber eben tatsächlich diese komische alte Ritterlichkeitsnummer. Dieses so, man tritt sich mit offenem Visier auf offenem Feld entgegen und irgendwie benutzt halt irgendwie die Waffen, die einem irgendwie sichtbar sind und ist nicht übermäßig irgendwie trickreich und so. Und andersherum ist natürlich also die Motivation, sich daran zu halten, ist natürlich einfach, dass den eigenen Leuten halt genau selbe passieren kann. Also dass man halt einfach sagt, okay, wenn wir irgendwie uns gegenüber den, also als Armee A, dem Feind gegenüber so zumindest einigermaßen fair oder ritterlich oder wie auch immer man irgendwie der Pseudo dort dann bezeichnen möchte, verhält, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit größer, wenn uns das passiert. Also wenn wir in Gefangenschaft kommen, zum Beispiel als Armee A, dass uns Armee B dann halt irgendwie ja auch gut behandelt. Aber am Ende ist natürlich irgendwie totaler Bullshit, weil es sich halt um Krieg so, aber interessant ist eben, wie wir von da zum Terrorismus kommen.
Naja, also es gibt da verschiedene Varianten, Aspekte daran, die sehr interessant sind. Also es gibt ja Dokumentationen über deutsche Kriegsgefangene bei den Briten. Und wenn es Offiziere waren, sind die wirklich gut behandelt worden, sind in so ein Herrenhaus gebracht worden, haben da irgendwie Alkohol und Zigaretten gekriegt.
Bis auf den kleinen Folterknasten.
Na klar, aber ich will sagen, da gab es durchaus...
Sie haben sich bemüht, den Anschein zu wahren. Also beide Seiten haben halt Offiziere gefoltert, wenn sie halt an Informationen kommen wollten und haben sie halt im Zweifel hinterher noch mal umgebracht, damit sie halt nicht darüber reden können. Also die Kriegsverbrechen, die da passieren, also ich meine, gut, das bietet diese Hager Landkriegsordnung wenigstens mal einen Definitionsraum für Kriegsverbrechen.
Genau, das ist das Neue an der Hager Landkriegsordnung, dass es das Konzept eines Kriegsverbrechens gibt. Und man muss auch sagen, als das geschrieben wurde, war die Einstellung zum Krieg auch noch eine ganz andere. Da war Krieg nicht so was wie, das ist das letzte Mittel, was man tut, wenn man irgendwie, man darf sich nur verteidigen. Ja, sondern das war ein legitimes Mittel, um Missverständnisse zwischen Staaten auszuräumen.
Oder Interessenkonflikte.
Es gab auch, ich kann es nur sehr empfehlen, sich mal nicht nur die Paragraphen durchzulesen, da stehen dann z.B. so Sachen drin wie, dass wenn offiziell Kriegsgefangenschaft ist, muss dem weiter Gold gezahlt werden. Aber abgesehen von solchen Sachen, gibt es auch interessante Aspekte, wie dass die Einführung sich verzögert hat. Selbst als sich alle einig waren, bei den Genfer Konventionen gab es so ein paar, also Genfer Konventionen gibt es auch mehrere davon, und da gab es halt trotzdem so eine Verzögerung von irgendwie zwei Jahren oder so. Und wo es heißt, historisch gesehen, ist nicht ganz klar, was eigentlich das Problem war. Und eine der Ideen war eben, naja, also da gingen eigentlich alle Beteiligten davon aus, dass es jetzt demnächst noch ein paar Kriege geben wird, weil das halt so Usus war, und dann wollten sie so mal noch warten, bis die aktuelle Runde steht. Also der Punkt ist jedenfalls, innerhalb von diesem Definitionsgerüst ist der Terrorismus eine Abwertung, weil dir nämlich die als Gefangener nicht die Rechte der Kriegsgefangenschaft zustehen, die sagen, du musst fair behandelt werden, sondern du hast nur rechte zweiter Ordnung und die sind nicht wirklich verbrieft oder definiert, sondern da steht halt so ähnlich, wie man sagt, Abgeordnete sind ihrem Gewissen verpflichtet, steht da drin irgendwie, naja, man soll so gucken, dass man sich an Moral irgendwie anstandt und Gewissen und so hält.
Naja, aber der Unterschied zu der Definition heute, wo es ja so ist, dass irgendwie kombatant definiert, als ja eben das Thema nach Guantanamo schicken kann.
Deswegen haben wir das so abt angesprochen, weil es heute eigentlich andersrum läuft.
Und zwar ist es ja heute so, dass eben dieser kombatanten Status, also dieses Benutzen von Kriegsrechtstermini eben dazu dient, den Leuten den Zugang zu den zivilen Gerichten zu verwehren. Also dafür zu sorgen, dass sie nicht im Rahmen ziviler normaler Gerichtsbarkeit abgeurteilt werden, sondern im Rahmen dieser Militärgeschichten bleiben. Deswegen ist ja eben dieser dieser Name, was haben sie denn nennt, illegaler kombatant?
Genau, illegale Kompatanten. Das ist eine Sache, die sich die Amerikaner ausgedacht haben, und zwar so 1942, 43. Da haben nämlich die Nazis ein Sabotage-Programm gestartet, wo es hieß, in Amerika deutsche Exilbewohner aktivieren, damit die dann da Sabotage durchführen. Und das haben die Amis halt natürlich enttarnt. Sowas fällt ja auch auf, wenn da Sabotage vorgenommen wird. Und da hat dann der Supreme Court davon gesprochen. Also das höchste Gericht, dass es dieses Konstrukt des Illegal Combatant gibt. Und daraus, also die Idee war quasi, das ist ein Combatant, weil er am Krieg teilnimmt, aber es ist keiner, der die Rechte eines Combatanten hat. Und das ist ein Konstrukt, mit dem man versucht, auf der einen Seite die zivilen Rechte, die nicht Combatant hat, wegzunehmen, aber auch die militärischen Rechte, die einen Combatant hat, wegzunehmen. Und dieses legale Konstrukt des illegalen oder ungesetzlichen Combatanten, da gibt es so eine lustige Liste in Wikipedia. Die Länder, die das haben, sind die USA, Großbritannien, Australien, Kanada und Israel. Also genau die üblichen Verdächtigen.
Die üblichen Verdächtigen, ok.
Gut, aber da kommt also diese Idee des Combatanten her. Das hat mit dem Völkerrecht und Kriegsrecht zu tun. Und das Lustige ist natürlich, ein Kriegsgefangener braucht einen Krieg. Also man kann nicht einfach Leute verhaften und sagen, das ist ein Kriegsgefangener.
Aber den haben wir mit dem War und Terror.
Man muss einen Krieg ausrufen. Und der ist eigentlich nur dann ausgerufen, wenn man entweder angegriffen wird oder wenn man ihn erklärt. Und das ist schon seit vielen Jahren nicht mehr passiert in Amerika. Deswegen ist das völkerrechtlich sowieso sehr dubios, da jetzt zu sagen, wir haben jetzt einen War on Drugs oder einen War on Terror. Und deswegen sind das alles Combatanten. Also das ist mehr als dubios. Das ist ihnen auch eigentlich selber klar.
Das ist halt eben einfach nur raus geredet. Also bis so in die 20er Jahre hinein war ja der Begriff des Terroristen abgelöst durch den Begriff des Anarchisten. Also da wurden ja die gewalttätige Anarchisten als, ja waren ja die Bombenleger damals, die halt den, ja tatsächlich mit Bombenanschlägen, ob nun echt oder gefaked, versucht haben, da irgendwas zu verändern. Und dementsprechend waren eben diese, ja die Anarchisten dann eben auch der, das Feindbild, was heutzutage der Terrorist ist.
Eine rein rhetorische Erinnerung. Inhaltlich war es das, genau.
Ja, ist ja genauso den, was man ja heute Extremist nennt. Also diese Extremismus-Geschichte ist ja eigentlich inhaltsgleich zu dem, was irgendwie in den 60er und 70er Jahren halt die Radikalen waren. Also da gab es ja im Westdeutschland den Radikalen alles.
Das kennt man heute nur noch aus der Chemie. Die freien Radikalen.
Wo dann Leute eben aufgrund ihrer Gesinnung verfolgt wurden oder nicht Lehrer werden durften oder nicht Beamte werden durften. Und der Begriff wurde jetzt abgelöst durch Extremismus.
Was ja auch ein Versuch ist, links und rechts Terror gleichzusetzen. Inhaltlich. Also eigentlich, Radikalismus sagt ja was anderes aus rein inhaltlicher als Extremismus. Es ist jetzt von der Wortbedeutung her wird es als Synonym benutzt. Aber Extremismus sagt ja entweder extrem links oder extrem rechts. Und Radikalismus sagt ja eigentlich mehr über die Mittel aus als über deine Positionen oder nicht.
Kann man so sehen? Also vielleicht ist es immer gut radikal, heißt dann eigentlich erst mal nur konsequent. Also kann man so sehen.
Also es ist für mich jedenfalls immer hochspannend zu sehen, wie sich so der Neusprech entwickelt und wie die Leute unter Druck sind, immer noch noch krassere und noch dramatischere, um mal Spiele online zu channeln, Sachen, Vokabeln zu finden, um die immer selben Sachverhalte immer schlimmer darzustellen.
Interessant ist ja natürlich dabei immer, dass die, als ob man sie jetzt irgendwie Archistener, Terroristen oder Extremisten oder Radikale nennt, ist, dass ja immer versucht wird, dabei noch den Ideenraum oder die Ideologie oder die Gesinnung, für die Leute stehen, die oder die Leute vertreten oder wie man es immer definieren möchte, die sich halt terroristischer oder sonstiger Mittel bedienen, dienen damit zu diskreditieren, also zu versuchen zu sagen, ok, Linksteurismus diskreditiert grundsätzlich auch erst mal die gesamte linke Idee und ähnliches. Und das natürlich dann...
Auch die Auswirkungen wird ja gleich gesetzt. Man sagt, die sind quasi zu denselben Sachen fähig, die Terroristen und die Rechtsterroristen. Und das ist historisch überhaupt nicht zu belegen. Also wir haben noch ein paar Beispiele.
Können wir nachher noch ein bisschen im Detail zuhören?
Also diese Terrorismusdefinition ist so schwierig, dass es ein witziges Detail gibt. Nämlich nach dem Angriff, nach dem Attentat auf die olympischen Spiele in München in 70ern, hat die UNO nämlich überlegt, ob sie vielleicht auch mal gegen den Terror was tun soll. Und haben sich also hingesetzt und haben überlegt, ob sie erstmal eine Terrordefinition machen. Ja, und dann ein Statement machen, so von wegen, ja, wir verurteilen das aufs Schärfste. Und Länder, die sowas machen, müssen abgekanzelt werden, blablabla. Und das hat nicht stattgefunden, weil sich vor allem die arabischen und afrikanischen Länder quergestellt haben. Und die haben damals argumentiert, wenn wir das machen, dass wir Terrorismus brandmarken, dann werden alle Länder ihre Aufständischen als Terroristen brandmarken. Und dann zementieren wir den Status quo.
Kommt einem irgendwie bekannt vor, oder?
Und das ist natürlich völlig richtig. Aber es ist rückblickend so ein bisschen, entbehrt das nicht in einer gewissen Ironie, dass ausgerechnet die Araber das gesagt haben, die jetzt heute selber ein Problem haben.
Genau so ist es passiert.
Also sie haben völlig recht gehabt. Inzwischen gibt es dann doch die UNO-Resolution 1566 vom Sicherheitsrat. Da sind dann weniger Leute dran beteiligt, aber es liest sich immer noch ganz gruselig. Könnt ihr ja mal googeln, das ist so eine ganze Seite Traktat. So mit Anwaltsdeutsch. So ja, das tun oder das nicht tun im Sinne von blablabla.
Conditional-Seel.
Ja, so fordert alle Staaten auf, solche Straftaten zu verhindern. Und wenn sie nicht verhindert werden können, sicherzustellen, dass zumindest eine Strafe verhindert wird. Also so Bandwurmsatz, formulierblabla. Und das ist halt ganz witzig, wenn man versucht, wenn man sieht, was es für Schwierigkeiten gibt, dieses Kampfwort überhaupt inhaltlich festzunageln, weil das so ein Gummiding ist, so ein Wackelpudding, den man an die Wand nageln will. Das klappt halt nicht. Und diese längliche Definition, da gibt es sicher immer noch Sachen, wo die nicht zutrifft, was man eigentlich trotzdem als Terrorismus bezeichnen würde.
Naja, es gibt ja diesen Spruch, dass irgendwie das einen Terroristen, das ist das andere ein Freiheitskämpfer.
Ja.
Und der ist natürlich gerade in diesem, also in diesem zitierten Diskussionsbeitrag der arabischen Staaten da. Stimmt halt. Das war damals schon genau so, aber die Russen damals in Afghanistan haben halt auch die Mujahideen als Terroristen bezeichnet.
Waren sie auch.
Waren sie auch objektiv. Also heutzutage werden sie wieder als Terroristen bezeichnet.
Die sind ja auch, weil sie radikale Extremisten waren von der CIA beauftragt worden, da mal ein bisschen Unruhe zu machen. Ja, aber es gibt da viele Begriffe, die eigentlich dasselbe oder ähnliche Sachen meinen, inhaltlich, aber wo es dann so geringe oder gar keine Unterschiede gibt. Also ich habe hier mal so eine Liste gemacht. Ich habe hier Widerstandskämpfer. Na, das ist irgendwie selbsterklärend. Ein Partisan ist eigentlich auch ein Widerstandskämpfer, aber man benutzt das historisch für die Widerstandskämpfer in den von den Nazis besetzten europäischen Ländern. Also ein konkreter Fall von, ein Sonderfall von Widerstandskämpfer. Der Plural ist Partisanen nennen und nicht Partisanen. Also nicht darauf reinfallen, wer denn da sucht. Ein Partisanen ist so eine Art helle Barde, so eine mittelalterliche Waffe. Also da kann man sich leicht vergugeln. So dann gibt es noch den Freischärler. Das geht auch aufs Kriegsrecht zurück. Eine Freischar ist eine paramilitärische Sache, würde man heute sagen. Also so eine Abteilung, die aber nicht Teil des offiziellen Militärs ist. Das heißt, eine freie Schar einfach von Leuten, die also Kompatanten showen, aber nicht Teil des offiziellen Militärs.
Das ist dann schon fast wie eine Miliz.
Genau, ist so ein bisschen wie eine Miliz. Inzwischen ist die Genfer Konvention wohl auch erweitert worden, um zu sagen, wenn der Einmarsch so schnell stattfindet, dass die Bevölkerung nicht genug Zeit hat, sich da in Armeen zusammenzufassen, dann gilt auch so eine Miliz als Kompatanten, wenn sie folgenden Anforderungen genügt. Also das ist alles ein hochspannendes Gebiet und ich kann dir nur empfehlen, sich da mal durchzuklicken. Alles sehr witzig.
Also am Ende ist es halt irgendwie dann doch wieder sehr theoretisch, weil irgendwie alle nur, wenn sie es so tun, dass sie darauf achten.
Aber einfach mal zu sehen, wie man versucht diesen Unsinn zu regeln. Ja, was sie da für Zeit verplempern und was es da für Abstufungen gibt, die ja eigentlich auch alle politisch motiviert sind. Also anderes Wort für Freiheitskämpfer ist ja auch guerrilla oder guerrillero.
Hochständische und Rebellen.
Genau. Und da ist ja auch, das ist ja wie mit ermorden und hinrichten. Das ist ja eigentlich auch meint dasselbe, aber die Frage ist halt, ob man das jetzt für legitim hält oder nicht. Also genauso ist das mit diesen Begriffen auch, wenn auch ein bisschen anders. Ja, paramilitärisch überhaupt heißt es, militärisch ausgerüstet, organisiert, aber nicht Teil der offiziellen Armee. Asymetrische Kriegsführung ist so ein modernes Wort dafür, dass man halt ein kleiner Mann ist, der sich gegen ein Riesenregime wehren will. Na ja, und Terrorist eben natürlich. Also der Punkt ist eben, ob man sagen will, ob eine bestimmte Person gegen das Kriegsrecht verstößt oder nicht, oder ob man überhaupt zugeben will, dass man Teil eines Krieges ist oder nicht. Und daher gibt es diese ganzen vielen Begriffe, die alle letztendlich sehr ähnliche Sachen meinen.
Interessant dabei ist natürlich immer, dass diese Taktiken ja auch nicht besonders neu sind. Also so historisch gab es ja da schon dieses Vorbild von den Assassinen.
Also, dass waren die berühmten Selbstmordattentäter im arabischen Raum. Und das war eine sehr, sehr spannende Angelegenheit, weil die politische Morde gemacht haben. Also die haben nicht wild irgendwie, es waren keine Auftragsmörder, sondern nach dem Motto, ich geb dir Geld und du killst den da hinten.
Da war es nicht politische Auftragsmorde?
Naja, aber sie haben irgendwie ein politisches Ziel gehabt. Also das heißt, das kam wohl selten wirklich überraschend, sondern das waren schon Leute, wo man sagen würde, die haben ein Bedrohungsszenario. Und dann ist halt so ein Assassin dahingegangen mit seinem Dolch, weil Sprengstoff gab es ja noch nicht so. Und hat ihn halt erdeulcht, aber die sind dann nicht geflohen. Sondern die haben sich dann dahingestellt und haben halt ihre Verhaftung und Aburteilung in Kauf genommen. Und das hat wohl psychologisch starken Eindruck hinterlassen bei den Umstehenden. Weil das eher selten ist natürlich. Ansonsten, dass der Mörder nicht zu fliehen versucht oder sich auch nicht widersetzt, wenn man ihn bestens zu nehmen versucht. Ja, es stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wenn man jetzt so einen Terroranschlag macht, ist ja abzusehen, dass so ein Staat darauf reagiert, indem er den Sicherheitsfaschograben hochdreht.
Dazu muss man vielleicht noch ein bisschen zurückgehen zu dem, was ist denn das Ziel von politischem Terrorismus? Da gibt es ja mehrere Abstufungen. Das eine Ziel ist natürlich einfach Verunsicherung, Chaos und allgemeine Destabilisierung.
Nein, der einfachsten Form ist es zu zeigen, dass es überhaupt Gegenwehr geben kann. Also wenn du in einer völlig aussichtslosen Lage bist, also man sagt so, wenn du eine Armee hast, dann versuchst du, das Land einzunehmen. Wenn du so ein paar kleine Kräfte hast, dann versuchst du, irgendwie einen Militärstützpunkt anzugreifen. Aber wenn du gar keine Aussicht auf irgendwelchen Erfolg hast, dann sprengst du wild irgendwelche Leute in die Luft, von denen du dann sagen kannst, irgendwie, das weiß ich, das waren Beamte im Unrechtsregime oder so. Aber jedenfalls Leute, die sich eigentlich nicht wählen können, um zu zeigen, dass eine Gegenwehr überhaupt möglich ist.
Oder halt einfach nur normale Zivilbevölkerung, um halt einfach das öffentliche Leben zum Erliegen zu bringen oder den Staat dadurch zu diskreditieren, dass man klarstellt, dass er nicht für Sicherheit sorgen kann. Das ist ja durchaus auch eine Strategie, die ja zum Beispiel von den Taliban angewendet wird, dass sie halt einfach sagen, solange wir hier nicht in der Macht sind, wird es halt Bomben auf den Märkten in Afghanistan geben. Und das ist natürlich eine relativ perfide Strategie, weil Gegenwehr gibt es dagegen fast nicht. Und am Ende wird sie dann vermutlich, so wie die Sache in Afghanistan aussieht, auch Erfolg haben. Als übrigens eine der wenigen terroristischen Strategien, die am Ende Erfolg gehabt haben, wird vermutlich.
Naja, nur haben sie ja die Bevölkerung dann auch nicht auf ihrer Seite, nachdem sie die jahrelang zerbombt haben.
Naja, das ist die interessante Frage, ob es nicht trotzdem dann zum Machtübergang kommt.
Naja, ich meine, Afghanistan ist ein Land, wo es nicht Spaß macht, an der Macht zu sein, wenn das Volk nicht hinter dir steht. Das kann man glaube ich aus der Geschichte lernen. Also jedenfalls, eine der wenigen Abgrenzungen von Terrorismus gegen Partisanenkrieg oder Kampf ist, dass man sagt, wenn man so einen Partisanenher hat, dann hat man trotzdem den Versuch zumindest oder das Ziel, Land zu gewinnen. Also man würde zum Beispiel erst im Süden Anschlag machen, in irgendeiner abgelegenen kleinen Stadt und würde dann sich vorarbeiten. Also man hat aber schon so territoriale Ansprüche. Man greift hier mal eine Militärbasis ein und da mal ein Konvoi oder so. Aber das ist ja nicht das Ziel des Terroristen, sondern der Terrorist, der versucht eben nicht Land zu gewinnen, sondern der versucht, dem geht es eher so um die PR, um zu zeigen, wir haben hier Leute verwunden können.
Terror zu verbreiten.
Genau, es geht um Terror. Das heißt, es geht gar nicht um das Tatsächlich. Also du greifst niemanden an, um ihm weh zu tun, sondern für den Effekt danach, wenn irgendwie die Presse sich drauf stürzt.
Je mehr Presse du hast, desto besser für deine Zwecke. Da kommen wir später noch drauf, bei der aktuellen Geschichte mit den Zwickauer Naziteuerristen.
Perfiderweise heißt es aber auch, dass je freier der Staat ist, desto besser funktioniert Terror. Wenn du wirklich ein Unterdrückungsregime gegen dich hast, die auch die Presse gleich geschaltet haben, dann hilft es überhaupt nicht, irgendwelche Terroranschläge zu machen, weil die Presse das dann einfach nicht berichten wird. Also dann gibt es vielleicht irgendwelche unklaren Gerüchte, aber ich meine, naja. Der wirkliche Terror entsteht ja dadurch, dass die Presse hingeht und Blut zeigt. Und wenn du eine gleichgeschaltete Presse hast, passiert das halt nicht.
Es sei denn, der Anschlag ist groß genug.
Es sei denn, die Regierung möchte das gerne ausnutzen.
Also ich meine, es gibt ja immer wieder Gerüchte darüber, dass es in Nordkorea eben auch Anschläge gibt, die eben nicht berichtet werden, also die halt offiziell nicht stattgefunden haben. Und in China gibt es ja auch diese Geschichten, dass solche Anschläge, wenn maximal überhaupt in der Lokalpresse berichtet werden oder als Unfall getarnt werden, wie zum Beispiel gerade im Iran, wo halt irgendwie die Terroranschläge der Israelis gegen die Raketenbasis da. Wo man sich dann, genau, das ist auch eine zentrale Frage, ist es halt Terrorismus oder ist es halt eine Special Forces Operation, die sie da machen, die Grenzen dazwischen sind halt extrem fließend?
Und letztendlich, wenn man sagt, das ist Selbstverteidigung, das ist ja auch nur eine Ausrede übers Motiv und das ist ja keine Aussage über die Art des Anschlages. Also man kann ja auch aus Selbstverteidigung einen Terroranschlag machen. Das Problem ist halt, wenn man die offizielle Definition von Terrorismus nimmt, also die einfache Wörterbuchdefinition, dass man einfach Gewalt anwendet für ein politisches Ziel, dann ist fast alles Terror, was irgendwie mit Polizeiunterdrückung und Gewalt zu tun hat. Also wenn man jetzt die Kastuartransporte sich betrachtet und wenn man sieht, dass die Tagesschau zeigt, wie da harmlose Passanten verprügelt werden, dann wäre das auch Terror nach der Definition. Also das ist eine sehr weitreichende Definition. Und deswegen gibt es eben sehr viel engere Definitionen dann bei den einzelnen Staaten, um zu versuchen, ihre eigenen Sachen da nicht drunterfallen zu lassen. Und da macht sich z.B. der Norm Chomsky jemanden Spaß draus. Der hat sich so eine Definition rausgesucht von einem Handbuch der US-Armee und wendet das dann eben an auf irgendwelche Militäroperation der Amerikaner im Ausland. Und wenig überraschend sind alle möglichen Sachen plötzlich Terror, wenn man das einfach wörtlich nach der Definition beschreibt. Und das ist eben das Schwierige bei Terror. Also Terrorismus im konkreten Fall ist fast alles Terrorismus, wenn man das nur richtig auslegt. Also das ist einfach ein Kampfbegriff.
Alle Gewalteinwände zu politischen Zwecken eben.
Und das wäre ja fast alle Gewalteinwendung. Kann man ja am Ende sagen, wenn da irgendjemand was von hat oder wenn du unterstellen kannst, dass da jemand was von haben wollte. Das reicht ja auch schon. Also das ist einfach ein Kampfbegriff, mit dem man im Grunde keine sinnvolle Diskussion führen kann, weil das halt ein Kampfbegriff ist und keine rationale oder irgendwie klare Beschreibung von irgendeinem Geschehen. Das ist einfach ein Kampfwort, was man benutzt, um den Gegenüber schlecht zu machen.
Interessant an diesen ganzen Anschlägen, wenn man die so historisch betrachtet, ist, dass zumindest gefühlter überwiegender Mehrzahl dieser Anschläge irgendeinen Staat seine Finger im Spiel hatte. Also wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie die Geschichte von staatlichem Involvement im Terror aussieht, da gibt es halt längliche Archive, kann man sagen, zu den einzelnen Terrorbewegungen. Bei jeder einzelnen davon findet sich halt irgendein Staat, der irgendwo seine Finger im Spiel hatte. Also eine der oder zumindest Strukturen, die halt staatlichen Ursprungs waren.
Häufig sogar der eigene Staat, also nicht immer nur ausländische Staaten. Also das geht jetzt von Fluchthilfe wie bei der DDR und den RAF-Terroristen geht's los und endet mit so Sachen wie irgendwelchen Gladiosachen. Da kommen wir gleich noch drauf, was Gladio war.
Aber das können wir eigentlich gleich mal machen. Ja, also die Idee von Gladio ist eigentlich fast nochmal eine eigene Sendung wert. Die können wir vielleicht auch noch mal irgendwann machen. Gladio war eine sogenannte Stay-Behind-Truppe in den NATO-Ländern, die dazu dienen sollte, wenn die Russen kommen, dann hinter der Front halt mit Terror, Partisanen-Kampf, was auch immer, halt denen das Leben schwer zu machen. Und halt auch wenn sie kommen, halt rechtzeitig die Sabotageakte denen halt das Vorkommen vordringen zu erschweren.
Wir hatten glaube ich in der Sendung das schon mal angesprochen, oder zumindest die Wahlmeister haben das mal angesprochen.
Ja, wir können es einfach noch mal kurz erzählen, so der Wiederholung.
Also es geht darum, das ist ein offizielles NATO-Ding, wo aber nicht die CIA beteiligt war, sondern wie heißt dieses DIA oder so, Defense irgendwas. Also einer von den vielen Geheimdiensten der Amerikaner, diesmal Teil des Militärapparats und nicht der zivilen Dings. Und die haben das halt in diversen europäischen Ländern gemacht. Und das Vorbild war die Nazi-Werwolf-Gruppen. Und das ist auch eine sehr spannende Sache.
Werwolf war halt eine Struktur, die die Nazis gegen Ende des Krieges aufgebaut haben, wo sie eben auch, wenn die Russen durch sind oder die Engländer und Amerikaner durch sind, hinter der Front durch Terroranschläge quasi dafür Unruhe sorgen sollten und dafür sorgen sollten, dass es eben keinen Frieden in den befreiten Gebieten gibt.
Wobei das lustigerweise viel größer eine PR-Sache war als ein tatsächlicher Anschlags-Dings. Also der einzige größere Anschlag, der dann immer zugewiesen wurde, war, später hat sich dann nach der Wiedervereinigung aufgrund der Stasi-Archive herausgestellt als Militäraktion und nicht als Wehrwolf-Aktion. Also eigentlich war das hauptsächlich so eine, der Terror war tatsächlich eine Terrorvereinigung, weil die nämlich bei den Alliierten Terror ausgelöst hat, ob es jetzt tatsächlich sowas gibt oder nicht. Also der der Goebbels hat dann halt angefangen, da irgendwas herbeizuschwadronieren und im Radio auszustrahlen, von wegen die Bevölkerung würde sich erwehren. Und da gibt es halt diese Wehrwolf-Truppen. Und ihr werdet ja sehen, was ihr davon habt, bei uns einzumarschieren. Und das hat wohl monatelang bei den alliierten Truppen für Angst und Schrecken gesorgt, dass sie damit gerechnet haben, dass sie da von irgendwelchen Stay-Behind-Einheiten plattgehauen werden, was aber nicht passiert ist.
Ja, und in der sowjetischen Besatzungszone diente das eben auch zur, kann man sagen, unsystematischen Verfolgung von relativ großen Bevölkerungsteilen. Also die haben dann halt einfach lauter Leute verhaftet und die beschuldigt halt bei Werwurf dabei gewesen zu sein. Teilweise zu Recht, teilweise zu Unrecht.
Mit erfolterten Geständnissen, also das heißt...
Und haben dann mit erfolterten Geständnissen halt noch mehr Leute...
Impliziert und die dann auch verfolgt, ja.
Genau, und am Ende wurden da mehr als 10.000 meistens Jugendliche verhaftet, die zum Teil tatsächlich wirklich radikalisiert waren und versucht haben, sich da irgendwas mit Widerstand zurechtzufantasieren, aber zum Teil...
Was anderes als Jugendliche gab es ja auch nicht mehr, ne?
Völliger Bullshit war, ja.
Das waren halt alles irgendwie, gab es nur noch die Männer, alle gefallen. Ja, aber also da hat sich die Sowjetinnen tatsächlich auch später für entschuldigt?
Genau, die wurden halt praktisch alle rehabilitiert, die die da damals beschuldigt und dann teilweise auch in die Arbeitslager geschickt und ja, und dann teilweise irgendwie erst irgendwie Jahre später entlassen worden.
Aber insofern voller Erfolg der Terrorstrategie, nicht so sehr der Anschlagstrategie, sondern der Terror hat funktioniert.
Genau, und der war halt zum größten Teil eben simuliert.
Gut, aber die Alliierten haben das halt gesehen und haben sich gedacht, na das funktioniert, das wollen wir auch und haben im Rahmen der NATO so Stay-Behind-Einheiten für die europäischen Länder, für die westeuropäischen Länder geplant. Und der Gedanke war eben, wenn die Russen kommen, dann haben wir da ein paar Leute und die können an die Brücken sprengen und die haben richtig Waffen und Sprengstoffdepots verteilt aus Militärbeständen, also auch richtig hochwertiger Sprengstoff, nicht irgendwie selbst gemixt, sondern die waren gut vorbereitet, hätten richtig gute Waffen gehabt und so weiter. Und haben sich zum Großteil aus irgendwelchen rechtsextremen Nazi-Seilschaften rekrutiert, weil der Feind nämlich ganz klar die Kommunisten waren. Wenn die Russen kommen und haben sie gesagt, na ja, dann nehmen wir doch jemanden, der eh schon was gegen die Russen hat. Und dann haben sie halt in den ganzen Ländern übrigens an den Parlamenten vorbei, zum Großteil oder in allen Fällen sogar. Also die Parlamente haben zumindest glaubwürdig simuliert, dass sie nichts wussten. Und dann gab es eben diese Einheiten, die in der Schweiz übrigens auch, also nicht nur in den NATO-Ländern, gab es eben diese Einheiten. Und als dann offensichtlich wurde, dass der Russe jetzt konkret nicht kommt, aber dass möglicherweise die Kommunisten demokratisch an die Macht kommen konnten, was in Italien ja tatsächlich mehrfach passiert ist, da haben die dann eben angefangen, die Gladio-Seilschaften zu benutzen, um Terroranschläge im Land zu fingieren, die man dann den Kommunisten in die Schuhe schieben könnte. Und das ist in Italien viele Jahre so gelaufen, tatsächlich.
Die Behörden haben dann jeweils die Beweise entsprechend so manipuliert, dass es erst mal so aussah, zumindest für die Presse, als wenn tatsächlich die Kommunisten, also kommunistische Untergrundzellen, für diese Anschläge verantwortlich waren, um dann eben entsprechend dazu Verfolgung zu schreiten und die halt auch zu diskreditieren öffentlich.
Die Strukturen für sowas, das ist natürlich relativ aufwendig, das mal eben aus dem Boden zu stampfen. Deswegen haben sie in Italien eine Abkürzung genommen und haben eine bestehende Geheimloge, die allerdings seit Jahren inaktiv war, wiederbelebt. Und die heißt P2, oder Italienische Propaganda Due. Und da waren also lauter alle, jeder der Rang und Namen hatte, im Grunde war drin, irgendwelche Regierungsräte, Industriellen, das heißt da war dann auch die Finanzierung kein Problem, sogar irgendwie ein Militär, das war da wohl auch drin. Also das heißt jedenfalls, diese Truppen von konservativen, rechtskonservativen Nazis, das volle Spektrum, haben eben Anschläge fingiert, um sie den Russen oder den Kommunisten in die Schuhe schieben zu können, damit bloß die Kommunisten, wenn sie dann in der Macht waren, wieder abgewählt werden oder gar nicht erst an die Macht kommen. Und das hat also nur zum Teil funktioniert. Aber es gab durchaus jahrelang echte Hysterie von wegen, die Kommunisten wollen uns alle umbringen.
Ja, meine, diese Strategie haben sie auch in anderen Ländern verwendet. Also zum Beispiel in Belgien, da gab es die, diese sogenannte Naive Gang oder auch Braband Killers. Das war eine ziemlich abstruse Geschichte, wo es eine Serie von Überfällen auf Supermarkte und Ähnliches gab, wo dann einfach Leute erschossen wurden. Also die wurden halt einfach umgebracht, so ohne großes Federlesen, ohne dass da größere Räube stattfanden. Und dabei wurde niemand irgendwie verhaftet und die Anschläge wurden mit ziemlich militärischer Präzision durchgezogen. Und dann gab es in der Presse halt eine längere Spekulation darüber, wer jetzt eigentlich nun dahinter steckt. Und eine der Gruppen, die dann halt eben gerade von der rechtskonservativen Presse beschuldigt wurde in Belgien, waren die sogenannten Zellus, Kommunistiskombattantes, mit der schönen Abkürzung CCC. Die deswegen in den 80ern Jahren halt die Abkürzung CCC zumindest in den flemischsprachigen Regionen nicht so richtig... Nicht durchgehend positiv belegt war. Genau. Die plausibelste Theorie über diese Neivel-Gängen ist, dass es sich dabei um solche Strukturen handelte, die eben aus dieser Gladio-Geschichte standen, die dann halt einfach benutzt wurden. Also, man hat da halt ein Geheimnetzwerk, die sind ordentlich bewaffnet, die sind ordentlich ausgebildet, die wissen, wie sie die Klappe halten können und die sind ja am Zweifel radikal rechts und wollen halt verhindern, dass zum Beispiel Regierungsstrukturen sich in Richtung sozialistischer oder kommunistischer wandeln.
Haben aber eine Befehlsstruktur, sind also keine irgendwie nervös werdenden Einzeltäter, die da dobe Fehler machen.
Und halt eben die Deckung der Behörden.
Das sind immer so Indizien. In Belgien gibt es noch keine wirklichen Beweise, aber es gibt halt viele Indizien und die sehen alle so aus nach dem Motto, die waren halt militärisch ausgebildet. Die haben irgendwie keine Anfängerfehler gemacht und die haben Zugriff auf richtige Hardware gehabt. In anderen Ländern gibt es tatsächlich Dokumente, die gefunden wurden. Also an erster Stelle seien hier Schweizer und Italien genannt. In Italien sind richtig irgendwie die Auftragsbriefe rausgekommen und da gibt es also keine Fragen mehr, was es da gab. In Deutschland gab es sowas auch.
Warte mal, lass uns kurz noch mal bei Belgien bleiben. Wir bleiben noch mal bei Belgien. Belgien hat ja, wie wir wissen, so eine gewisse Historie, was bei diesen Doutro-Morden hochkam, so eine gewisse Historie von Kinderbordellen und Zuführung von Minderjährigen für Orgien von Politikern. Und interessant bei dieser Neivel-Gang ist, dass unter anderem dabei Leute umkamen bei diesen Überfällen von denen, die da was mit zu tun hatten, also die zum Beispiel Filme von solchen Partys gehabt haben sollen oder gewusst haben sollen, wer da was tut. Und da bietet sich so das Bild eines irgendwie echt größeren Sumpfes, in dem eben so eine Strukturen wie Gladio, die ja eben durch ihre Vernetzung mit irgendwie Sympathisanten in den Behörden auf der einen Seite und natürlich den politischen Voraussetzungen auf der anderen Seite benutzt werden konnten, um da zum einen Terror zu verbreiten, also was man wieder versucht, den Linken in die Schuhe zu schieben, und zum anderen halt eben auch lästige Zeugen aus dem Weg zu räumen. Das heißt also, die wurden, zumindest ist das eine relativ plausible Theorie, waren die halt einfach Killer-Kommandos, deren Taten dann eben auch noch politisch benutzt wurden. Also interessant war ein Freund von uns, der meinte, als er von dieser Zwickauer-Geschichte hörte, also den Nazister, so das erste, was ihm halt einfiel, waren diese Neivel-Killer.
Ist ja genau dasselbe, was wir auch mal hatten.
Genau, so klingt doch irgendwie alles sehr, sehr ähnlich.
Vor allem, wenn man so eine Gladio-Truppe beauftragt, um peinliche Details wegzukriegen. Wir hatten das ja mal in der früheren Alternativlossein kurz angesprochen, wie so Geheimbünde funktionieren und dass sie darauf basieren, dass jeder gegen die anderen Kompromat in der Hand hat. Insofern ist das auch eine selbst verstärkende Angelegenheit und danach haben beide den Grund, sich nicht gegenseitig zu verpfeifen. Also solche Strukturen, das muss ja gar nicht so geplant gewesen sein, aber selbst wenn sich das zufällig ergibt, schweißt das eben zusammen. Gut, aber es sind halt Indizien. In manchen Ländern ist es überhaupt nie aufgeklärt worden. In Deutschland gab es Ansätze, aber es ist eigentlich weit großflächig gescheitert, hat ja die Aufklärung.
Ja, also der Rechtsterrorismus in Deutschland hat ja auch schon etwas längere Geschichte, wo eben diese Gladius-Sachen eben auch wieder mit reinspielten. Die bekannteste, also wenn man ein bisschen zurückgeht in die Geschichte, die bekannteste Struktur, da war die sogenannte Wehrsportgruppe Hoffmann, die also aus dem Anfang der 70er, 1973 wurde die gegründet, 1980 wurde sie verboten und diese Strukturen waren ja quasi bewaffnete Nazis, die sich militärisch zusammengerottet haben, um ja zusammen zu trainieren und dann eben auch entsprechende illegale Aktivitäten, also Anschläge zu verüben. Und diese Strukturen hingen häufiger eben zumindest am Rand mit diesen Gladius-Strukturen zusammen. Sei es, dass die halt Waffen bekommen haben oder Sprengstoff aus, oder dass sie halt ähnliche Personalüberschneidungen hatten, dass man da halt verstehen muss, dass es da halt eine Menge Leute gibt, die halt sehr ähnliche Gedanken haben. Also die halt eine sehr, sehr ähnliche Weltsicht haben, die halt irgendwie antikommunistisch antilinks ist und die halt versuchen dann mit allen Mitteln, den Feind aufzuhalten, aus ihrer Sicht.
Und wenn man denen sagt, der Strauß braucht euch, dann kommen die halt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es der Strauß konkret war, wahrscheinlich galt ja auch irgendwie die Linker-Weichlink oder so.
Ein freiheitlicher Politiker gewesen. Also dieser Oktoberfest-Anschlag jedenfalls, der riecht auch ziemlich aus dem Mund.
Genau, also das war halt so ein Anschlag, der jetzt gerade auch vor einigen Tagen wieder hochkam, als im Spiegel sich dann plötzlich der Akten manifestierten, aus denen hervorgingen, dass die schon damals wussten, dass der Attentäter damals, der 26. September 1980, da sind 13 Menschen bei gestorben, zwar hat El Fefe zum Teil schwer verletzt worden.
Das war natürlich ein Einzeltäter, ein irrer Einzeltäter. Da müssen immer die Alarmglocken angehen, wenn so ein großer Anschlag von einem verirrten Einzeltäter gemacht wird.
Was man sich überlegen muss, ist, die Logistik von so einem Anschlag ist halt nicht ohne. Als Referenz, wenn man sich diese Tagebuchaufzeichnung von diesem norwegischen Attentäter anguckt, die sind halt sehr schwer lesbar, aber zumindest kann man da mal sehen, was der für eine Energie, einen Aufwand und ein Geld da reingesteckt hat, um diese Bombe zu bauen. In der Regel haben einzelne Menschen nicht diese Energie und diese Möglichkeiten.
Und wie lange das auch gedauert hat? Der hat ein Jahr oder so Vorbereitung da gehabt.
Und deswegen, wenn man da halt so eine Einzeltäter-Thesen hat, da sollte man immer relativ vorsichtig sein. Meistens treffen die nicht zu. In dem Umblick, also hier bei dieser Oktoberfest-Geschichte, ist es halt so, dass der Attentäter hatte halt eine lange Historie von Kontakt zu solchen Nazi-Gruppen, unter anderem halt irgendwie diesen Wärtsportgruppen. Der hatte offensichtlich auch Zugang zu militärischen Sprengstoffen. Also der Sprengstoff, den er verwendet hat, war halt da TNT. Und er wusste offenbar auch, wie man solche Bomben baut. Und also diese ganze Geschichte riecht halt deutlich aus dem Mund.
Das ist übrigens ein spannender Aspekt an der Stelle, das man sehen kann. Bei vielen rechtsgerichteten Terroranschlägen geht es wirklich wild in die Bevölkerung. Da werden einfach Leute zerbombt. Also bei diesem Oktoberfestding, da hat ja nicht nur TNT am Start gehabt, was ja schon übel genug ist, sondern noch Schrauben und Nägel da rein getan. Und selbst wenn dich das nicht tötet, muss dir dann danach irgendwie die Beine amputiert werden oder so. Also das ist schon echt bösartig. Also das sieht man leider häufiger bei rechts-terroristischen Anschlägen, dass die da wenig Zurückhaltung haben und sich überhaupt nicht bemühen, nur ihre Ziele zu treffen, sondern da ist dann Maximierung des Kollateralschadens angesagt.
Das ist ja interessanterweise auch bei diesem Anschlag in Italien, in Bologna, auf den Bahnhof, den sie auch erst versucht haben, den Roten Vigaden, also den örtlichen Linkstor-Rosten in die Schuhe zu schieben.
Und wo die Aufklärung so gar nicht vorankam danach.
Ja, wo hinterher aber klar war, dass der von der Propagandadur organisiert worden war. Und auch da war es halt ein wahlloser Anschlag. Also halt einfach wahllos die Leute auf dem Bahnhof umgebracht, zumindest zum größten Teil. Und diese Charakteristik, ja, sagen wir mal relativ wahllos, Leute nicht umzubringen wegen ihrer Funktion oder ihrer Stellung in der Gesellschaft oder dem, was sie repräsentieren, was ja eher so bei den linkstoristischen Anschlägen eher der Fall ist, wenn sie sich gegen Personen richten, sondern eben Leute einfach nur umzubringen, um einen Punkt zu machen. Den findet man eben gerade bei rechtstoristischen Anschlägen häufiger oder eben auch bei Anschlägen, die von Rechtstoristen fingiert werden, um sie dann wiederum den Linken in die Schuhe zu schieben.
Also als Kontrast sei vielleicht mal die IAA genannt. Die haben ja auch wild umgebombt und auch Bahnhöfe und so, aber die haben dann wie eine Stunde vorher einen wahren Anruf gemacht von einer öffentlichen Telefonzelle. Und da hat die Polizei dann Zeit gehabt, das zu räumen. Dann haben wir die Bombe entschärft und das hat richtig Geld gekostet, einen Monsteraufwand, um das dann zu entschärfen. Aber da ist halt selten wirklich irgendwie 100 Leute ermordet worden. Als Kontrast dieses angebliche Al-Qaeda-Ding da in Spanien, das ist auch so ein Ding, was aussieht, als wenn es darum ging, möglichst viele Leute umzubringen. Aber der Terror kommt ja eigentlich nicht daher, dass du da Leute umbringst, sondern daher, dass die Leute Angst haben, sie könnten umgebracht werden. Insofern ist das eher kontraproduktiv eigentlich, da möglichst viele Kollateralschäden zu haben. Aber gut, das Problem in dem Umfeld ist eben, dass man viele Sachen nie aufklären kann, weil das immer von irgendwelchen Geheimgruppen gemacht wird. Und ob die jetzt staatliche Geheimbünde oder nicht staatliche Geheimbünde sind, da ist jedenfalls an die Daten schwer ranzukommen.
Und häufiger ist es eben so, dass jetzt gerade auch in neuerer Zeit, also bei den Islamisten zugeordneten Anschlägen, fällt es schwer, einen zu finden, wo nicht schon irgendwelche Dienste ihre Finger im Spiel hatten. Also wo nicht die Zünder von irgendeinem Geheimdienst geliefert wurden oder irgendeiner der Leute, die damit rumlief, halt irgendwie bei irgendeinem Geheimdienst noch einen Nebenjob hatte. Oder zumindest einer der Leute, die dann später für diese Anschläge halt beschuldigt oder verurteilt werden, zwischendurch mal Zuträger für irgendeinen Geheimdienst war und genauso stellt sich das dann eben auch bei den Rechtsterristen in der Geschichte da. Interessant ist halt bei dieser, also noch so ein Bild, was mir gerade unterkommt, bei dieser Wehrsportgruppe Hoffmann, also damals dieser Nazi-Terrorgruppe, die wurde dann irgendwann verboten durch den Innenminister damals Baum, Gerhard Baum. Und wer sich dagegen aufgeregt hat, war damals der bayerische Ministerpräsident Strauß.
Ausgerechnet.
Ausgerechnet der, genau. Der hat das dann kritisiert und meinte, es ging ja zu weit so, ne?
Also lustigerweise, ich hab hier gerade so eine Statistik, weil die so schön passt, die ist mir aufgefallen beim Log-Auswerten für die Fnord News Show. Und zwar hieß es da, mit drei Ausnahmen waren alle Domestic Terror Plots aus den letzten zehn Jahren in den USA FBI Stings, also Undercover-Operationen mit FBI Informanten oder also halt Stings eben, ne? Und das lässt doch tief blicken, ne? Also ich würde sogar so weit gehen, ich hab das ja auch ein paar mal geblockt bei irgendwelchen Sachen, wenn keiner verletzt wird, weil sie das aufklären können, bevor da fertig gebaut ist, dann würde ich eigentlich immer davon ausgehen, dass da irgendwie ein Staat involviert ist. Denn wenn jetzt eine Regierung kommt und sagt, wir wollen jetzt einen Terroranschlag fingieren, weil wir mehr Sicherheitsgesetze brauchen, dann kann man ja, wenn man noch so ein bisschen rechtsstaatlich irgendwie Grundgedanken hat, dann kann man ja keine Leute umbringen dafür, ne? Also das ist immer so.
Zumindest erhöht es die Lästigkeit später.
Ja, das, naja gut.
Also ich meine, wenn Leute umkommen, sind die auch deutlich lästiger.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber so weit sind wir im Moment noch nicht. Man würde jedenfalls sagen, wenn da tatsächlich Leute umkommen, halte ich es für deutlich unwahrscheinlich. Ja, sagen wir es lieber so rum, dass tatsächlich das von irgendwelchen Diensten gemacht worden ist. Inländische Dienste, also zum Ziel der Terrorerhöhung. Na ja, ich meine, das ist ein Merkmal bei Gladio, dass die Parlamente nichts wussten. Also die Frage ist, ob ein Parlament das wirklich machen würde.
Ne, gut, das Parlament sicherlich nicht. Aber interessant ist natürlich auch die Mechanismen, wie es dann halt funktioniert, wenn dann mal so was auffliegt. Also bei Gladio zum Beispiel gab es so einen Vorfall, da ist so ein Nazi aufgeflogen namens Heinz Lemke, der Waffendepots angelegt hatte in der Lüneburger Heide. 33 Stück, in denen sich Kram aus Armee bestanden befand. Also Sprengstoff und Munition und Waffen und Ausrüstungsgegenstände. So was man halt so braucht. Und zwar richtig viel, also so viel für so einen mittleren Krieg halt. Und den haben sie halt dann festgenommen. Und der sollte dann halt vernommen werden durch einen Staatsanwalt. Und der wurde dann einen Tag davor, vor seiner Vernehmung in seiner Zelle erhängt, aufgefunden.
Klarer Fall von selbst.
Klarer Fall von selbst und natürlich so. Und sowas passiert halt in diesem Gladio-Umfeld halt häufiger. Also das ist halt so ein durchaus charakteristisches Zeichen. So also die war jetzt auch ja bei dieser Zwickau-Geschichte so. Da haben sich auch alle gewundert, wieso irgendwie diese überlebene Terroristin da halt irgendwie noch tatsächlich noch lebte. Und eigentlich war doch...
Das war ja auch wirklich erstaunlich.
Ja, eigentlich ist es sehr erstaunlich. Also die Wetten standen ja dann doch eher auf immer merkwürdiger Selbstmord und weniger Tage.
Bedeutlicher Unfall.
Ja.
Also wir sollten vielleicht noch sagen, wenn wir sagen, Sprengstoff aus Armeebeständen, das ist tatsächlich ein anderer Wirkungsgrad als selbst zusammengebaute Bomben. Und zwar so eine Größenordnung, oder wie täuscht sich das wahrscheinlich?
Ja, also nicht eine ganze Größenordnung, aber schon signifikant. Also man braucht sehr viel weniger Volumen, um halt eine gleichgroße Sprengwirkung zu erzeugen.
Insofern, wenn jemand Sprengstoff aus Armeebeständen hat, das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich deutliches Zeichen. Das hat mich auch bei der RAF gewundert, dass sie dann irgendwelche Bundeswehrbestände leer zur Räume versucht haben. Das liegt zwar irgendwie nahe, aber ich würde es, also wenn, ich versuch das jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig zu formulieren, wenn ich einen Terroranschlag machen müsste, dann würde ich mir den Sprengstoff doch lieber selber bauen, als den von der Bundeswehr zu klauen. Weil wenn du dabei erwischt wirst, dann hast du ja erst mal vollständig verkackt, während man sich vielleicht bei irgendwelchen selbstgebastelten Dingern irgendwie noch am ehesten rausreden kann. Jedenfalls noch eher, als wenn man da irgendwie auf dem Bundeswehrgelände ertappt wird, mit denen hinten an den Granaten gestätten.
Na gut, was damals halt schon der Fall war, ist, dass diese Depots nicht besonders gut gesichert waren. Und da also schon, also auch bei den Nazis, wo sie da Sprengstoff gefunden haben, haben sie hinterher festgestellt, dass also die Sicherheit an diesen Depots eher ziemlich laschow war und es halt auch einfach nicht wirklich schwierig war, wenn halt schon eine organisierte und bewaffnete Gruppe bis zu einer Lage ist, Aktivitäten durchzuführen, da so ein Bundeswehrdepot zu plündern, war zumindest damals eine eher nicht so schwierige Operation. Also deswegen sind die auch mehrfach gelungen bis hin zu diesen diesen Wallmeister-Depots, also wo sie halt Sprengstoff, der für diese Brückensprengung für den Fall einer Invasion vorgesehen war, sich da besorgt haben.
Unglaublich. Naja, aber ich mein, also so rein irgendwie leihenhaft von außen gesehen, würde ich mir das schon inkommodierend vorstellen, wenn dann so ein Späherpanzer der Bundeswehr hinter dir herrollt, um dir den Sprengstoff wieder abzunehmen. Geringt wirklich weniger unerfreulich als...
Also gut, ich meine, klar, ist halt auch passiert, da sind ja auch Leute bei etab- worden, so bei solchen Depot-Pflünderungen, aber eigentlich ist es der Klassiker, dass du halt erst mal versuchst, dir aus irgendwelchen schlecht bewachtener Medipos halt irgendwie ordentlichen Sprengstoffen, ordentliche Zünder zu besorgen, um anstatt dir anzufangen, dir kritische Chemikalien zu beschaffen.
Wobei die ja inzwischen auch ordentlich überwacht werden. Na ja, früher war das ja wohl viel weniger so.
Früher war es viel weniger so, aber klar ist halt...
Da warst du einfach Landwirt, wie dieser Norwiger, das er auch gemacht hat. Dann hat sich dann da halt eine Düngerbombe gebastelt. Aber das war wohl auch weniger einfacher, als er sich das vorgestellt hat, anhand der Internet-Planne.
Das Tagebuch liest sich doch eher so, als wäre das ganz schön anstrengend gewesen. Na ja. Dann kommen wir mal zu diesen Naziteuristen. Ihr habt vermutlich irgendwie alle so halbwegs verfolgt. Also diese drei Nazis, die sie da festgenommen haben in Zwickau. Einen haben sie festgenommen, zwei nur noch tot aufgefunden. Und wie immer in solchen Fällen gibt es halt diverse Merkwürdigkeiten. Also unter anderem halt auch Sprengstoff und angeblich auch Waffen aus irgendwelchen Armeebeständen, was uns ja wieder zu diesen klaren Merkwürdigkeiten bringt, wo es ja ähnlich war.
Ja, das ist immer ein klares Zeichen, um sich da erstmal Sorgen zu machen. Und nicht irgendwelche Dienste. Aber in diesem Fall war es ja noch übler. Die haben ja gefälschte Ausweise von Verfassungsschutzniveau. Also tatsächlich von der Bundesrückerei dann, ne? Also echte Ausweise sind nur falsch ausgestellt.
Ja, sie haben sich jetzt irgendeine Story zurechtgelegt, dass es wohl angeblich mit einem manipulierten Paar, so sie sich einen neuen beschafft hätten oder so. Aber das klang alles sehr, sehr fischig. Also die Frage, wo die Waffen herkamen, ist auch noch eine spannende Frage typischerweise. Wenn so ein Geheimdienst so eine Terrorgruppe unter Kontrolle bringt, dann manipulisieren die halt erstens erstmal die Waffen zuvor. Weil dann wissen sie halt, wenn was passiert oder wenn irgendjemand irgendwo gefunden wird, ob es jetzt ihre Leute waren oder ob es irgendjemand anders war.
Na und man beobachtet natürlich, das war ja auch bei diesen Nazis so, dass alle möglichen Fälle dann bekannt wurden über die Jahre, Jahrzehnte gar, wo dann jeweils ein Verfassungsschutzbeobachter in der Nähe gesichtet worden war. Naja, nicht nur Beobachter, naja, aber dass es zumindest der Teil jemanden irgendwie beweisen kann.
Naja, es war halt so, dass an mehreren dieser Tatorten ein Verfassungsschützer wohl anwesend oder in der Nähe war. Einmal saß er halt sogar in der Kneipe selber drinnen. Und bei dem sie dann halt hinterher irgendwie Nazi-Memoriabler zu Hause gefunden haben, also irgendwelchen Nazi-Kram.
Ein harmloser Sammler, bin ich mir sicher.
Ja, das ist sicher ein harmloser Sammler, der bei sich im Dorf irgendwie Kleiner Adolf hieß. Also sicherlich ein komplett harmloser Sammler. Dann gibt es halt eine lange Reihe von Hinweisen auf Kontakte zwischen zumindest dieser Frau Czepa und dem Verfassungsschutz. Die waren 13 Jahre im Untergrund und es gab irgendwie konkrete Hinweise vom MAD auf diese Truppe, die halt nicht verfolgt wurden. Dann hatten sie ein offenbar großes Supportnetz, was...
Also das alleine finde ich ja schon den Hammer, weil der MAD ist ja eigentlich nicht zuständig für die Verfolgung von Einzeltätern.
Es ist ja denn, es geht zum Beispiel um die Liebstahlsbundeswehr-Depots und da kommt er halt ins Spiel.
Also ich meine, ich will sagen, wenn der MAD bei dir aufschlägt und sagt, hör mal, wir haben hier einen Hinweis, dann gehst du dem nach, weil irgendwie die kommen nicht, weil du ein kleiner Spinner irgendwie möglicherweise sich da indoktriniert liest, sondern das ist konkret.
Ja, und was ich jetzt halt abzeichnet, dass die halt ein riesiges Supportnetzwerk hatten, die alle von denen wussten und die halt über 13 Jahre im Untergrund supportet haben in so einem Umfeld, was so dermaßen infiltriert ist, so dass irgendwie, also der Spiegel schrieb halt, in den 90er-Jahren hat der Fassungsschutz mindestens drei Leute im Umfeld von dieser Zelle gehabt. So und mittlerweile hat es...
Aber du willst auch immer die großen Fische haben und nicht die kleinen. Deswegen lässt du die kleinen mal ein paar Leute umbringen. Da fragt sich natürlich, wen die da eigentlich gesucht haben, wenn sie dann solche Leute nicht festnehmen.
Dann vor allem die Dimensionen. So, also die Taz hat jetzt Informationen, dass es BKA insgesamt 160 von der wirklich verschwundene Person aus der rechten Szene identifiziert hat. Also wo sie halt nicht mehr so richtig wissen, was die tun, wo die stecken. Also da fragt man sich denn schon, so 160 Leute ist ja irgendwie nun nicht so ganz ein Pappenstil.
Ein halber Bundestag.
Nicht ganz, wir haben 666. Und dann natürlich diese ganzen Fragen halt mit dem Mord an der Polizistin Nöchve Kiesewetter, die ja offenbar im Zusammenhang zu ihrer, also zu dem Ort stand, wo der eine herkam. Dann gab es irgendwie so Geschichten, dass es irgendwie zwei sehr ähnlich aussehende Phantombilder gab von Tätern aus der Kölner Kolbstraße, wo halt einer der Morde stattfand, aus Nürnberg, wo ein anderer Mord stattfand. Und da sogar ein Journalist darauf hingewiesen hat, dass es da eine Ähnlichkeit gibt und der wurde halt abgebürstet. Nee, das wird schon nicht so passen. Also reden Sie mal nicht drüber. Und dann diese ganzen Ungereimtheiten im Zusammenhang mit den Selbstmorden. Mittlerweile sagen sie, dass der eine den anderen und dann sich selbst erschossen hat.
Mit einer langen Waffe.
Mit einer langen Waffe, so also...
In einem innerhalb von diesem Camping Wohnmobil. Ja, also das...
Ja, und die Anwohner, die da so teilweise zehn Meter weg wohnen, sagen, sie haben halt keine Schüsse gehört. So ein angeblich halbes Gesicht, der halt mit einer Schrotflinte erschossen. Und so eine Schrotflinte ist dann doch eher laut so. Also selbst wenn sie in so einem Campingmobil abgeschossen wird.
Haben vielleicht Rammstein gehört.
Völlig. Und dann jetzt, was sie da nach und nach rauspolken aus dem Haus da, angeblich da irgendwie, meinten wohl schon mal Feuerwehrleute, die da bei dem Löscheinsatz waren, so dass sie das doch sehr, sehr merkwürdig finden. Was sie da irgendwie noch Tage nach dem Brand alles aus diesem Haus rauspolken, wo ja, also doch irgendwie sehr komische Artefakte zutage kommen, die eigentlich nicht so ganz zu dem Brandbild passen. Dann gibt es diese Geschichte im Stern. Das angeblich, die es eine Observation gab von der DIA, also dem amerikanischen Militärgeheimdienst, wo sie in der Nähe waren des Start-Ots, wo die Michael Kiesewetter erschossen wurde und dann die Observation abgebrochen haben, wo sie irgendwelche Islamisten, Banker observiert haben. Gut, also die wurde halt...
Wo haben sie das eigentlich her gehabt? Das sah fast aus, vom Format her, wie so ein Wikileaks-Depesche.
Völlig unklar, ja. Also ich meine, das passt zeitlich, glaube ich, nicht ganz. Und zwar so ein DIA-Akt, da wüsste ich jetzt nicht, dass die schon geliebt sind.
Nee, aber also das war eine völlig bizarre Geschichte. Naja.
Naja, und dann...
Aber das gibt es tatsächlich häufiger, dass noch irgendwelchen Anschlägen festgestellt wird, dass der Verfassungsschutz, die eigentlich schon seit 20 Jahren überwacht hat, und das dann alle so, wie konnte denn das passieren?
Und oder im Zweifel halt seine Finger im Spiel hat. Also meine Theorie dabei ist ja, dass es sich halt, also gerade mit dieser Geschichte, mit diesem Verfassungsschützer, der an den Tatorten war, das klingt für mich so, als hätte da auch so eine Gladio-artige Struktur gegeben, die nachdem die RAF jetzt weg war, wo sie brauchten, sie halt irgendwie neue Killer-Truppen, mit denen sie halt irgendwie Morde begehen konnten oder Anschläge begehen konnten. Und dann haben sich halt ein paar Nazis gecastet. So, das mag zwar vielleicht erst mal ein bisschen wild klingen, aber diese ganze Struktur...
Du musst auf diese diese Gerüchte noch eingehen, dass die Nachfolgegeneration bei der RAF...
Achso, ja, das sollte man vielleicht noch erwähnen. Also es gibt ja relativ persistente Gerüchte, dass die letzte RAF-Generation halt, oder zumindest die letzten zwei, dass die zumindest in einer Art und Weise unterwandert war oder gesteuert war vom Staat oder einfach nur der Name benutzt wurde für ganz andere Morde, wo also dann die Anschlagsziele eben nicht... Also wo dann diese Klassenkampf-Argumentationen in den Bekennerschreiben kamen, dann eben nur noch fake war und es da aber eigentlich darum ging, halt irgendwie politisch misslebige Personen aus dem Weg zu räumen, die halt irgendwie, ja, Leuten im Wege waren. Und die Gerüchte sind natürlich relativ persistent und werden natürlich immer wieder dementiert, aber klar ist halt, dass es da hinreichend viele Ungereimtheiten gibt. Und klar ist eben auch, dass es eben eine Historie von solchen, ja, Kildertruppen gibt, die halt unter politischem Label dann halt eben in der Lage waren zu agieren und dafür, dass sie, ja, sagen wir, Staatsaufträge erledigt haben, dann eben auch irgendwie die Freiheit hatten, andere Sachen zu tun, die dann wiederum benutzt wurden, um ja, den, ja, den Staat mit der Argumentation zu versehen, halt mehr Sicherheitsmaßnahmen durchzudrücken.
Wir müssen diesen Klassenkampf noch erklären. Das ist nämlich aus der RAF Dokumentation, aus den Begründungen, die haben ja Bekennerschreiben und längliche Traktate verschickt. Und das ist so eine eine der Sachen, aus die ich mich aus meiner Kindheit wirklich gut erinnere, dass es im Fernsehen immer hieß, die hätten nur abstruses Zeug gebracht und da müssen wir uns gar nicht mit auseinandersetzen, weil das eh totaler Schwachsinn ist. Und das war also so die Linie im Fernsehen, immer in der Tagesschau und so, dass keiner auch nur angefangen hat zu erklären, was sie da eigentlich konkret geschrieben haben. Und ich dachte immer, naja, vielleicht haben die in Code geschrieben und so, weil ich dachte, was soll denn das? Wie kann denn das so abstrus sein, dass die nicht mal versuchen, das zusammenzufassen? Und das waren halt so fundamental marxistische Sachen und Ideologien, wo es dann am Ende als Idee darum ging, dass man die Bevölkerung vielleicht nicht direkt agitiert kriegt, aber man kriegt sie indirekt agitiert, indem man den Staat provoziert, dass er seinen Faschismus sich demaskiert, indem man einfach Terroranschläge macht und der Staat reagiert dann durch Verschärfung seiner Infrastruktur. Das hat ja auch stattgefunden, aber es hat eben nicht gereicht, um die Bevölkerung aufzubringen. Im Gegenteil. Also das ist immer so ein Mythos, den es bei vielen Terrororganisationen gibt, dass die sich denken, wenn wir nur den Staat dazu kriegen, uns doller zu verfolgen, dann sieht die allgemeine Bevölkerung, was das für ein Faschoregime ist und wehrt sich, aber das passiert halt nicht.
Ja, aber dass eben genau diese These von der Verschärfungsklassenkampf ist, die kommt halt immer wieder hoch und bisher gab es glaube ich nicht so besonders viele erfolgreiche.
Wir haben vorhin schon überlegt und uns ist keins eingefallen, wo das mal funktioniert hat.
Also wenn euch einer einfällt, wo die These von der Verschärfungsklassenkampf wirklich tatsächlich funktioniert hat, dann schreibt uns doch eine Mail.
Naja, also dieses Involvement ist ja auch nicht nur Beobachtung, sondern als V-Mann kriegt man ja Geld. Das heißt, es gibt einen Anreiz dafür, sich als V-Mann zur Verfügung zu stellen und denen dann gar nicht zu helfen. Und tatsächlich scheint das ein gängiges Geschäftsmodell unseres Nazis zu sein, dass die sich den Verfassungsschutz als V-Mann zur Verfügung stellen, sich anwerben lassen oder vielleicht sogar sich bewerben. Es gibt ja eine Hotline für Aussteiger, Terroristen. Genau, da kann man sich dann hinwenden und kann sagen, man will jetzt V-Mann sein und dann kriegt man halt pro Information, die man denen gibt, irgendein Geldbetrag. Das ist also jetzt nicht irgendwie kein Lotto-Gewinn, aber das ist auch nicht völlig unsignifikant, vor allem, weil das ja pro V-Mann ist. Pro V-Mann, pro Information. Das heißt, wenn sich da so ein Dutzend V-Männer zusammentun, dann können die mit dem Erlös aus den Bullshit-Informationen, die sie weiterreichen, auch mal so eine Parteigründung finanzieren.
Über die sie dann wieder berichten können.
Über die sie dann berichten können. Und das ist auch tatsächlich mal passiert. Also es gibt so ein Video, wo sich ein Typ aus NRW, war das glaube ich, interviewen lässt von Aspekt oder so, einem von diesen Politmagazinen, als es die noch gab. Und wo der erzählt hat, ja, wie haben wir da die NPD überhaupt nur gründen können, weil wir vom Verfassungsschutz so viel Geld gekriegt haben?
Für die Formantätigkeit.
Für die Formantätigkeit, ja. Und das ist so ein Kreis, der sich auch selbst verstärkt, weil beide Seiten Interesse daran haben, das aufrechtzuerhalten. Und da gibt es halt keine Notbremse. Es gibt niemanden, der irgendwie das hinterfragt, ob wir da jetzt eigentlich gerade für unser Geld was kriegen oder nicht, oder ob das alles Verarfung ist. Und das scheint ein wirklich gängiges Geschäftsmodell zu sein. Und der Nazis, das hört man immer wieder in irgendwelchen Büchern und Interviews, dass sie das so machen.
Interessanterweise taucht es vereinzelt auch sogar bei den islamistischen Terroristen auf, dass die dann von den Nazis lernen, als Siegen lernen, entweder als Ausrede benutzen gegenüber ihren eigenen Leuten, wenn sie irgendwie enttarnt werden als Spitzel, oder es tatsächlich ebenso ist. Also es verschwimmt dann halt alles in so einer Grauzone mit irgendwie doppelt, dreifach und vierfach Loyalitäten, die man dann halt überhaupt nicht mehr aufklären kann, was halt eben ein Kennzeichen von diesen Geheimdienstspielchen ist, so die halt früher halt irgendwie im Bereich der Gegenspionage getrieben werden und heutzutage halt irgendwie im Bereich von Unterterrorismus gegen Terrorismus betrieben werden, ja. Naja, was hat denn der Staat da so an Gegenstrategien gegen Terrorismus zu bieten? Also eigentlich...
Wir haben ein bisschen überlegt und so viel gibt es da gar nicht. Also wenn man sich überlegt, was man tatsächlich gegen den Terrorismus tun kann, nicht was der Staat tun kann, aber was er tun kann, was tatsächlich gegen Terrorismus hilft.
Ja und ich meine, die eigentlich die beste Strategie ist eigentlich Totschweigen, also dafür zu sorgen, dass halt einfach der, also zumindest bei echten politischen Terrorismus, dass halt einfach das marginalisiert wird, dass halt irgendwie keine Panik ausgelöst wird, keine, ja.
Es gab da einen Versuch, er ist fehlgeschlagen, Punkt. Also wenn man es nicht mehr leugnen kann. Ansonsten muss man gar nicht erst ansprechen.
Oder halt eben so, wie die Norweger es halt gerade getan haben, dass sie halt gesagt haben, ne, es ist halt passiert, lass uns mal trotzdem weitermachen, so hier.
Aber wenn man da anfängt, die Blutlachen zu zeigen, oder die die Polizeisirenen und den Menschenauflauf und das Blitzlichtgewitter, dann befördert man das überhaupt erst.
Genau und dann setzt sich der Staat natürlich auch schnell dem Verdacht aus, dass ihm die Sache eigentlich durchaus recht ist, weil er halt damit eben starke Überwachungs- und Sicherheitsgesetze durchprügeln kann, die er dann wiederum auch für andere Sachen verwenden kann, zum Beispiel zur Stabilisierung des politischen Systems. Und da gibt es ja natürlich wiederum eine Menge Strategien. Also da ist halt so die erste, ist halt natürlich irgendwie möglichst die Blutspritze und die Panik im Fernsehen zeigen, also den Terroristen halt helfen. Die zweite ist natürlich den Gegner zu entmenschlichen, also abstrakt darzustellen, sodass er halt nicht mehr irgendwie einzelne Menschen ist, sondern irgendwie ein übermächtiges Gebilde erscheint, also eine Struktur, die den Staat zum Gegner hat. Also auch diese Dualität, also so ein dualistisches Weltbild zwischen dem Staat und den bösen Terroristen aufzuziehen.
Na und man muss natürlich betonen, dass es denen gar nicht irgendwie um abstrakte Dinge geht, sondern die wollen euch umbringen.
Genau, also die politischen Aspekte aber halt einfach völlig marginalisieren und rauslassen.
Insofern war das eine schlaue Strategie, was die mit der ERF gemacht haben in meiner Kindheit.
Dass sie von den politischen Hälften nichts gezeigt haben.
Genau, nichts davon an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht haben, sondern nur gesagt haben, ja, das sind halt so ein paar Spinner. Aber letztendlich muss man eine Sache realisieren, nämlich dass der Staat überhaupt gar kein Interesse daran hat im Allgemeinen, den Terror zu unterbinden, weil er das nutzen kann, um sein Sicherheitsapparat zu rechtfertigen. Und die Politiker haben ein Interesse daran, dass es ein Sicherheitsapparat gibt, selbst wenn es keinen Terror gäbe, weil der nämlich auch sie schützt, wenn sie mal Scheiße machen.
Vor dem Zorn der Bevölkerung.
Vor dem Zorn der Bevölkerung. Das heißt, ein Politiker hat ein ganz persönliches Interesse daran, dass es ein Sicherheitsapparat gibt und dass die Bevölkerung keinen Aufstand macht. Und um den zu finanzieren, macht es spieletheoretisch Sinn, so einen Terroranschlag zu dulden.
Oder zumindest Versuche, die dann unterbunden werden.
Ja, und wenn man je nachdem, wie weit man auf der Faschismus-Gala ist, macht es irgendwann auch Sinn, selbst einen durchzuführen.
Und zur Illustration haben wir jetzt eine neue Folge von El Fefe.
Gegen Frank Guevara. Wir haben uns gedacht, wir machen mal ein Prequel. Wir machen es jetzt wie Hollywood, die keine Ideen mehr haben. Wir haben jetzt auch keine Ideen mehr. Wir machen ein Prequel. Wie wurde El Fefe eigentlich zum fiesen Diktator?
Genau, wie ist El Fefe an die Macht gekommen?
Ja, also es geht damit los, dass El Fefe ein Funktionär bei der Konservativen Stabilitätsunion ist, oder CSU, die strukturkonservativ für die freie Marktwirtschaft und angemessene Entlohnung für Arbeit einstegt. Also gemeint ist natürlich, dass Manager für ihre hohe Verantwortung auch hoch bezahlt werden. So und mein erstes Ziel als El Fefe ist die Einführung eines Personalausweises. Und da benutze ich den Vorwand von irgendwelchen ausländischen Schieberbanden für sozusagen.
Man muss dazu sagen, El Fefe ist zu dieser Zeit irgendwie nur der Staatssekretär im Innenministerium.
Genau, wir fangen ganz weit vorne an. Es gibt noch so gut wie keine Überwachungsinfrastruktur, keine Kameras auf den Straßen, keine geometrischen Datenbanken.
Absurdistan ist ein ziemlich pießiges Land. Die CSU-Elite, also von der konservativen Stabilitätsunion, die ist ein bisschen luschig und ein bisschen korrupt, aber die hält sich halt an der Macht. Aber El Fefe will halt mehr.
Ich will mehr und ich überlege langfristig, was ich machen soll. Als Erstes brauchen wir erstmal einen Personalausweis, damit die Leute das Gefühl haben, sie werden zur Rechenschaft gezogen, wenn sie etwas tun, was uns nicht gefällt. Und fangen also an, mir da irgendwas mit ausländischen Schieberbanden auszudenken und dass man die nicht erwischen kann, wenn man keine Ausweispflicht hat und erzähle irgendwas von illegalen Einwanderern und Nutzen, also die abstruse, absurde, generische Angst vor Fremden aus, um da Scheiße zu erzählen. Und ich sage, deswegen brauchen wir einen Personalausweis mit Lichtbild.
Aber so richtig hat der El Fefe nicht so den... Also er redet zwar immer davon, aber niemand will ihm so richtig zuhören. Also das ist halt eigentlich nicht so eine... Also die Einzigen, die ihn wirklich ernst nehmen, ist halt die Opposition so, die halt irgendwie...
Na, ich hab ja noch mehr Ziele.
Ja, klar. Gut, ja.
Also ich hab... Es geht ja noch weiter, meine Ziele. Ich meine, die erziel ich natürlich nicht öffentlich, aber ein weiteres Ziel ist natürlich, dass ich ein Kompromat habe. Im Moment bin ich ja nur so ein blöder Staatssekretär. Also ich mach da vielleicht die Sachentscheidungen, aber ich hab da noch nicht die Kontrolle. Und deswegen möchte ich gern ein bisschen Kompromat haben, um mir da mehr Zugriff zu sichern, mehr Entscheidungsbefugnisse. Und das Land hat aber noch gar keine Infrastruktur dafür. Also ich brauch jetzt einen Plan, wie ich die aufbauen kann. Brauche einen Geheimdienst, das ist ja immer völlig klar, damit ich Kompromat sammeln kann. Brauche Datenbanken über die Bevölkerung, ein bisschen Infrastruktur zum Abhören und so weiter. Na ja, und da gibt es eigentlich nur zwei Sachen, um das voranzutreiben. Entweder ich täusche einen Terroranschlag vor, rede ihn herbei, der muss ja gar nicht wirklich stattfinden. Ich muss nur genug Angst davor schüren. Oder ich lasse ihn geschehen. Oder vielleicht habe ich auch Glück und lebe in einer instabilen Gegend, wo die Nachbarn ständig Krieg gegen mich führen wollen oder wo ich das glaubwürdig simulieren kann. Oder wo es irgendwelche rassistische Ressentimenten gegen Ausländer gibt, die ich ausnutzen kann. Na ja, und als erstes nehme ich natürlich rhetorisch Anlauf und erzähle von Kriminalität und Bedrohung ausländischen Banden und organisierter Kriminalität. Und habe nicht den Hauch eines Beweises, aber den brauche ich ja auch nicht an der Stelle. Und wenn jemand nachfragt, dann bügele ich das ab mit Hinweis auf laufende Ermittlungen und erkläre in den Nachrichten, im Fernsehen, dass wir da nichts offenlegen können, um die Kriminellen nicht vorzuwarnen.
Na ja, also die Opposition hat da nicht so richtig eine Chance gegen den rhetorisch verkauft sich, dass wir haben gar kein Kriminalitätsproblem, was objektiv wahr wäre, gerade in Absurdistan, verkauft sich nicht so gut, wie halt diese wagen Andeutungen, die El Fefe da im Fernsehen immer von sich gibt. Und zumal er dann halt auch diese kriminellen Fälle aufbauscht und irgendwie so halb ausländerfeindliche Stichworte immer gerne mit dazu bringt. Es gibt halt eine große Oppositionspartei, ist irgendwie die populäre Demokratische Familienpartei, kurz PDF, die sich halt so als Partei der Armen und Entrechteten positioniert. Die will eigentlich auch gerne mal in die Macht, aber versuchen, die die Elite von der Konservativen Stabilitätsunion zu stürzen. Aber ja, die sind halt so ein bisschen opportunistisch und irgendwie lassen sich im Zweifel halt mit Brocken und Reformchen abspeisen und haben zwar eine breite Basis, aber können nie so richtig die Mehrheit davon erzielen. Ich bin also 10 Jahre Mitglied da. Ich bin halt Anführer einer Strömung, die sich zunehmend radikalisiert und die halt irgendwie von diesen Antikriminalitätsmaßnahmen von El Fefe ganz schön angepisst ist. Und wir wollen da halt eigentlich auch was dran ändern. Und also meine PDF Jugend, die organisiert dann halt eine Massendemonstration. Die ist allerdings, weil Fefe die Presse ganz gut im Griff so ist, die nicht so besonders gut besucht.
Ja, also mein Kulturministerium hat ein Konzert geschedult daneben und da sind die Leute natürlich lieber hingegangen. Aber eine Demonstration ist ja an sich schon mal nicht schlecht. Meine Polizei rechnet in Hochrechnung mit ungefähr 500 Demonstranten. Ich schicke also ungefähr 1000 Polizisten hin und nochmal 100 Provokateure. Und die haben die Aufgabe dann in die anwesenden TV-Kameras Gewaltbereitschaft zu signalisieren. Und vielleicht auch mal ein paar Steine auf die Polizisten zu werfen. Und die müssen sich ja dann wehren, die armen Opfer. Und in den TV-Nachrichten haben wir dann einen Satz zu der Demonstration, einen Satz und fünf Sätze zu der gewalttätigen Ausschreitung am Rand der Demonstration durch die fiesen Anhänger der PDF, die ihre Leute nicht im Griff hat. Und es wird ein Polizeiexperte befragt und der erklärt, dass die Ausrüstung der Polizei dieser Gewalt nicht gewachsen ist und hier dringend nachgebessert werden muss.
Angesichts irgendwie der Bilder von brennenden Polizeifahrzeugen und Ein verletzter Polizist, der immer wieder gezeigt wird. Genau, und den mehrfach verletzten Polizisten hat dann halt die Führung der patriotischen, wie haben wir sie genannt, der patriotisch-demokratischen Familienpartei nicht wirklich eine Chance. Die muss ich halt davon von meiner radikalen Jugendgruppe distanzieren. Das ist halt irgendwie, naja, so die älteren Herren, die eigentlich nur ein bisschen Sozialismus wollen und eigentlich keine Revolution. Und dementsprechend spaltet sich halt diese Jugend ab. Und ich bin halt jetzt der informelle Anführer dieser Gruppe, die natürlich inhaltlich ziemlich zerstritten ist, weil sie natürlich sagt, ja, die Polizei hat versucht uns aufs Maul zu hauen, da müssen wir jetzt mal was gegen tun. Und wir haben halt irgendwie da von der Polizei so viel Gewalt erfahren, die haben uns den Krieg erklärt. Und wir müssen da entsprechend antworten.
Ja, das ist natürlich überhaupt nicht, was ich haben will, dass meine Gegner sich da wegdezimieren. Die brauche ich ja noch. Wie soll ich denn mein Sicherheitsapparat ausbauen, wenn sich meine Gegner wegdezimieren? Also schicke ich da ein mir gewogenes Fernsehthema hin. Das heißt, ich schicke die nicht, sondern die sitzen da ja und warten darauf, dass ihnen informanten Sachen zuspielen. Also spiele ich ihnen ein Dokument zu. Und das kann man mit ein bisschen gutem Willen so lesen, dass die PDF nach wie vor heimlich die Abspalter von Frank Guevara mitfinanziert. Und weise darauf hin, dass die Terroristen sich im Internet radikalisiert haben, führe bei der Gelegenheit die verdachtsunabhängige Vorratsdatenspeicherung ein.
Na ja, die PDF-Jugend ist natürlich irgendwie davon extrem angepisst. So eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist ja schon eine massive Überwachungsmaßnahme. Und ein paar radikalisieren sich da so weit, dass sie Brandanschläge auf Polizei, Wachen und Außenstellen des Innenministeriums verübt, um eben gegen diese Überwachung zu protestieren. Und die Anschläge sind halt so organisiert, dass keine Menschen zu Schaden kommen, nur irgendwie so Gebäude und Autos und Funkanlagen und sowas. Und dann werden da halt auch Bekennerschreiben hinterlassen. Und die ist halt von einer Gruppe der radikalen Freiheitsfreunde, kurz GRIF, die sich dann zu diesen Anschlägen bekennt. Und ja, also um halt irgendwie mal den Punkt zu setzen und klar zu machen, so geht es halt nicht weiter.
Ja, also meine Strategie ist völlig klar. Ich schicke meine Untergebenen in die Talkshows und zu den Zeitungen schreiben sie Kolumnen. Und die schreiben, wir überrauen einen wehrhaften Staat. Das ist die erste Botschaft, die ich da vermitteln möchte. Der Staat darf nicht kapitulieren vor diesen gewaltbereiten Jugendlichen. Und dann schicke ich jemanden von der Polizei-Gewerkschaft hin und der erzählt der Presse, dass die Ausrüstung der Polizei nicht reicht und wie der Staat auf so einem, auf dem linken Bein so erwischt werden konnte. Da waren die überhaupt nicht vorbereitet. Gibt es da keine Vorbereitung, keine Aufklärung? Haben wir keine Geheimdienste? Und mit dieser rhetorischen Munition bewaffnet gehe ich dann los und gründe erst mal einen schönen Inlandsgeheimdienst, nenne ihn Hauptamt für den Schutz der Demokratie und Verfassung und gebe ihm umfangreiche Schnüffelbefugnisse, die er auch gleich zum Kompromat sammeln einsetzen kann.
Und warum es nämlich El Fefe eigentlich geht, sondern nämlich die Kompromate?
Darum ging es mir eigentlich, genau.
Na ja, das ist natürlich für die radikale Oppositionsbewegung schon eher so ein bisschen scheiße. Also wir schreiben, versuchen halt da mal ein bisschen gegen anzuschreiben, gegen diese Auswertung der Überwachung. Und ja, versuchen El Fefe als den eigentlichen Mann hinter diesen Überwachungsgeschichten zu entlarven. Aber so richtig interessieren tut es eigentlich niemanden. So das ist halt so ein bisschen das Problem. Und dann gibt es eine Woche später gibt es noch ein anderes Traktat von einer Gruppe, die nennt sich Echte Griff. Und die erzählen halt, dass man den Klassenkampf verschärfen muss.
Und taucht auf Indymedia auf.
Man muss halt irgendwie den Klassenkampf von unten verschärfen und das System noch viel stärker angreifen, um es eben in den Faschismus zu treiben und die Volksmassen zum Aufstand zu bewegen. Und mein Griff distanziert sich davon natürlich so ein bisschen und sagt halt irgendwie naja, also wir heißen halt keine Gewalt gegen Menschen gut so. Und wenn es halt sein muss, dann halt vielleicht Gewalt gegen Sachen, aber sonst kann man da halt es halt eigentlich nicht argumentieren. Und ja, das ist halt ein bisschen schwierige Situation, so wie es halt immer ist, wenn so eine radikale Bewegung sich dann halt auch noch durch Spaltung schwächt. Aber uns bleibt halt nichts anderes übrig. Wir haben halt irgendwie versucht, ein reines Gewissen zu haben.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine gute Gelegenheit, wenn ich schon den Ball habe. Dann schaffe ich doch gleich mal ein paar mehr oder weniger glaubwürdige Zeugen herbei. Und die erklären der staubenden Presse, dass sie gesehen haben wollen, dass die Terroristen hinter den Anschlägen gegen die Polizeirevierer am Anfang, dass die ja auch an einer Polizeikontrolle vorbeigelaufen sind. Leider haben wir ja keine Ausweispflicht in diesem Land, aber das muss sich jetzt ändern. So geht das nicht weiter. Ich führe also wegen der Aufklärbarkeit von Terroranschlägen ein Personalausweis mit Lichtbild und die generelle Aussichtspflicht ein.
Tja, naja, langsam wird halt die Radikalisierung immer stärker. Und dann einige Elemente aus der Griff, also den verübenden einen Brandanschlag auf das Zentrale Finanzamt, bei der halt eine Menge Unterlagen draufgehen. Und die Medien verdammen das natürlich, weil die Haushaltslage ist natürlich wie immer scheiße so. Allerdings ist es bei der normalen Bevölkerung, findet es halt schon eine gewisse Sympathie, weil, naja, Finanzamt, so, wer mag das schon? Diese ganze Sache ist aber dann natürlich, ja, ja, nur sozusagen unterschwellig. Und interessanterweise, was dann als nächstes passiert, ist, dass die echte Griff, also diese, die radikale Splittergruppe, die eigentlich niemand so richtig von uns kennt, aber die halt sich echte Griff nennen, die erschießt auf offener Straße den Finanzminister. Also zu sagen, eine normalen Eskalationsstufe weiter. Und am Tatort werden Hülsen aus der Produktion von Nordanien gefunden, das ist ein Nachbarland, das ist also der Erzfeind von Absurdistan. Und also es sieht halt so ein bisschen so aus, als wenn die echte Griff halt irgendwie Support aus Nordanien bekommt, was natürlich die Gelegenheit für El Fefe ist.
Skandalöserweise haben wir keine Überwachungskameras und können daher nur, können uns nur auf Zeugenaussagen verlassen und haben keine Beweise. Das muss anders werden. Ich lasse sofort Überwachungskameras an öffentlichen Orten installieren. Die Auswertung findet an zentraler Stelle statt. Und zwar habe ich mir die Bundesstelle für Fußgängersicherheit, Umweltschutz, Gleichstellung und Forstwirtschaft ausgedacht. Die sitzt im selben Gebäude wie der Speicherbunker des Bundesarchivs. Also neutral.
Ganz neutral. Und gut, also ich meine, das ist halt eine völlig unerträgliche Auswertung der Überwachung. Und die also die Griff startet eine Kampagne, bei der unsere Jugendlichen die Kameras, die El Fefe hat anbringen lassen, von der Wand reißen oder besprühen. Und dann ja um gegen die Überwachung zu demonstrieren und dann Zlogens daneben sprühen, Plakate kleben, um halt diese Überwachung am Alltag irgendwie zu vermeiden. Dummerweise versucht dann die echte Griff, also die richtige Terrorfraktion, einen viergeschlangenen Anschlag auf den Generalstaatsanwalt, der gegen die ermittelt und auch gegen die Griff, also meine Bewegung ermittelt.
Also offensichtlich arbeiten die Griff und die echte Griff zusammen oder sind sogar dieselbe Organisation. Ich lasse also meine Experten in den Talkshows rückhaltloser Aufklärung fordern und verspreche ein größeres Budget für Polizei und Dienste, sowie ein gemeinsames Koordinierungszentrum von Experten. Das kennt ihr vielleicht auch aus der Staatsanwesenden-Debatte, das kommt immer gut. Eine Datenbank-Zusammenführung und Führer neben den etablierten Repressiven auch präventive Polizeibefugnisse ein. Das hieß bei uns Beases BKA-Gesetz, die bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung angefallen sind. Datenbanken stehen jetzt der Polizei auch präventiv zur Verfügung. Mein Geheimdienst greift natürlich eh schon die ganze Zeit darauf zu. Also es funktioniert alles wunderbar.
Ja, uns bleibt nix weiter übrig, uns halt von diesem Anschlag der echten Griff, also von diesen ganzen Anschlägen, dazu zu distanzieren. Und wir müssen uns da irgendwie auch namentlich so ein bisschen absetzen. Und wir benennen uns dann um von Griff in friedliche, radikale Demokratiefrunde, kurz FRD, was leider zu gewisser Verwirrung bei allen führt. Und ich versuche dann irgendwie die Sache klarzustellen und führe halt mit hohem Aufwand ein anonymitiertes Telefoninterview mit einem Piratensender, in dem ich halt schon mal klarstelle, dass aus meiner Sicht halt die echte Griff, also diese Terrororganisation offensichtlich von El Fefe gesteuert wird, weil irgendwie alles, was die tut, spielte mir nur in die Hände.
Ja, das wird Zeit für einen meiner V-Männer. Der tritt der Presse gegenüber als Griff-Insider aus und packt aus und erzählt peinliche Details über die enge persönliche Verknüpfung zwischen Fritt und Griff und den Sauerland-Terroristen-Alkeider und der echten Griff. Also alles dieselbe Laden im Grunde. Teilweise haben sie sogar Betten geteilt. Sodam und Guevara sag ich euch, ich kündige ein paar Strafverfahren an. Es gibt eine landesweite Razzia, bei der einige 100 Aufwiegler festgenommen werden, von denen man nie wieder was hört. Mit der Eröffnung der Verfahren lasse ich mir Zeit, damit die Presse schon rumfantasieren kann, denn man muss da ja nicht vorgreifen.
Ja, es ist natürlich scheiße, gegen so ein Profi wie El Fefe zu spielen. Uns bleibt nix weiter übrig, wir distanzieren uns von diesem Vormann. Das ist ja ganz klar, logischerweise. Wie wir dann von befreundeten Umweltschutzgruppen mitgeteilt bekommen, hat der schon vor fünf Jahren in so einer Umweltorganisation als Spezial agiert. Es war alles dokumentiert, und wir haben es so in Dover-Weise übersehen, dass wir nach dem Gesicht noch mal googeln müssen. Das Problem ist natürlich nur, dass innerhalb der FRD eine ziemlich große Hexenjagd losgeht auf die V-Leute. Dann gibt es noch diese Verhaftung von El Fefe. Es führt zu gegenseitigen Misstrauen und Säuberungen in einigen Gruppen. Die Leute können sich eigentlich nicht mehr gegenseitig vertrauen und haben primär damit zu tun, herauszubekommen, wer denn jetzt eigentlich die Spitzel sind. Mit dieser V-Mann-Aktion hat El Fefe uns da halt auch in ein ziemliches Chaos geritten. Allerdings muss man sagen, dass wir von denen, also es gibt ein paar Leute, die sich haben als Vorleuter anwerben lassen, die das auch offen sagen und auch heimlich die Treffen mit den V-Mann-Offizieren, also den Führungsoffizieren mitschneiden und das Geld halt getreulich bei unserer Untergrundkasse abliefern. Also El Fefe finanziert uns halt auch im Untergrund direkt so ein bisschen über diese Vorleute.
Das mache ich doch gerne. Das ist auch alles auch im gegenseitigen Interesse. Man muss ja sagen, bei solchen Verhaftungen ist immer eins der Ziele auch, dass man Leute verhaftet, die eigentlich gar nichts gemacht haben. Einfach, wenn man sie dann freilässt, können die die anderen trotzdem nicht mehr glauben. Weil das ist auch eine Zersetzungsmaßnahme. Da geht es gar nicht so nur um die Repression, sondern es ist auch zukunftsgerichtet. Ja, aber zu der aktuellen Lage, da gehe ich natürlich zur Presse und lausiere da ein paar Gerüchte von teilweise geständigen Terroristen, führe eine Kronzeugen-Regelung und ein Zeugenschutzprogramm ein, um quasi den Anderen zu erwecken, die gibt es wirklich und ich werde auf sie zugehen. Und über geschickte Überschätzung der persönlichen Gefährdungslager Einzelnen enthaftiert, da kriege ich in der Tat einige Hinweise auf weitere Terroristen. Die verhafte ich aber nicht sofort, sondern spreche in der Presse von flüchtigen Terroristen und potentiellen Massenmördern, um weitere Sicherheitsinfrastruktur begründen zu können.
Ja, die Lage sieht für uns natürlich ganz schön scheiße aus. Aber es sind nicht alle Leute komplett demoralisiert. Und wir haben noch eine kleine Gruppe von technisch versierten Leuten. Und wir schaffen es halt während der Parlamentsrede von Fefe, wo er eben dann noch weitere Sicherheitsinfrastruktur fordert, den staatlichen Fernsehfeed zu übernehmen und da eine Propaganderede von mir einzuspielen, wo ich halt El Fefe und die V-Leute enttarnen kann und klarmachen kann, dass irgendwie alles, was Fefe da tut, ist halt ein Versuch, unsere Bewegung zu diskreditieren und uns mit V-Leuten zu unterwandern und zu versuchen, alles eben nur in die Hände spielen zu lassen. Und interessanterweise findet zumindest diese Rede doch einen relativ großen Anklang, weil sie natürlich deutlich besser ist, als das, was sonst so im Parlament läuft.
Ja, diesen Terroristen glaubt eh keiner, aber ich lass lieber nichts anbrennen und verhindere einen Terroranschlag am Hauptbahnhof. Für die Kameras hab ich da ein paar IST-Flaschen hingelegt und auf die Bahn ist eh keiner gut zu sprechen, weil die immer zu spät kommt. Und ich hab die ja auch so kaputt gespart und meinen extravaganten Sicherheitsapparat muss ich ja irgendwie finanzieren. Mein Ministerium für Verkehrsstatistik spricht von Zehntausenden an potenziellen Opfern bei den Terroranschlägen, die ich gerade verhindert habe. Ich bau natürlich meinen Geheimdienst weiter aus. Der hat inzwischen genug Kompromat am Start, um mir den Innenminister nervös zu machen. Und der erwägt gar die Befugnisse des Geheimdienstes kritisch zu dieser Frage und verspricht der Presse mehr Transparenz. Das geht natürlich gar nicht, der muss da weg. Ich schicke ihn also auf Dauertour durchs Land und sorge dafür, dass die Presse gebrieft ist und ihm auf die große Bedrohung des Landes anspricht und nicht auf die Intransparenz des Geheimdienstes. Und damit er ein bisschen beschäftigt ist und nicht umnervt.
Ja, also die FAD schafft es dann in einer heroischen Aktion einen Gefangentransport mit Leuten, die immer noch einsitzen, also die nicht freigelassen wurden, weil sie vor Leute waren, anzuhalten und die Gefangenen zu befreien. Da gibt es halt nur irgendwie einen Leichtverletzten bei, also es ist sozusagen noch zu vertreten. Wir befreien da halt 40 Leute, die natürlich von El Fefe intensiv verfolgt werden, weil sie natürlich jetzt im Untergrund, also sie müssen halt richtig in den Untergrund gehen. Das Problem dabei ist natürlich, dass halt irgendwie so 40 Leute im Untergrund zu versorgen, irgendwie strapaziert halt natürlich unsere Finanzen und unsere Organisationskapazitäten halt schon ziemlich doll. Bisher haben wir halt eher so als halboffene Struktur agiert, die halt irgendwie nicht so richtig im Untergrund war. Aber halt jetzt so 40 Leute im Untergrund zu versorgen, ist halt schon richtig dramatisch schwierig. Und die Leute im Untergrund, denen geht es natürlich scheiße und folgerichtig radikalisieren, die sich halt natürlich auch zunehmend. Und die Sache wird natürlich dann dadurch erschwert, dass die echte Griff halt einen erfolgreichen Einschlag auf den Innenminister verübt, den Fefe ja doch irgendwie ein bisschen lästig fand. Und Fefe wird daraufhin zum neuen Innenminister ernannt.
Na, das läuft ja prächtig. Ich räume umgehend dem Geheimdienst noch mehr Befugnisse ein und fange mal an, den Kompromatkoffer für den Premierminister zu sichten. So eine Beförderung, da muss es ja noch nicht enden. Na ja, und es stellt sich raus, dass er seiner Ehefrau untreu ist und ein Drogenproblem hat. Prima. Damit sorge ich dafür, dass er mir nicht im Wege steht und mich da schäubeln lässt, wenn ich Lust habe. Übrigens, dass die Leute im Untergrund sind, das lasse ich natürlich so, weil das ist ja perfekt für mich. Es gibt für die Bevölkerung so ein Bedrohungsszenario, was die sich einreden können. Und die Leute machen in der Zeit auch nichts Böses. Und wenn sie doch was Böses machen, spielt es auch mir in den Händen. Das ist noch viel besser, als wenn ich da auch noch, wenn ich die verhafte, dann muss ich ja fürs Gefängnis zahlen. Das ist ja viel besser so. Hatten doch niemanden anders die Kosten.
Naja, das läuft ja toll. Tatsächlich eine Strategie, die uns auch ganz schön zu schaffen macht. Also die Leute im Untergrund, wie gesagt, die radikalisieren sich halt zunehmend und fangen dann halt an, mal auf das, was sie als die Wurzel des Übels ansehen, hinzugehen und verüben halt eine Reihe von Anschlägen auf Banken und so industriellen Clubs und so ähnliche Einrichtungen, um eben auf die schreiende soziale Ungerechtigkeit hinzuweisen, die durch El Fefe's Maßnahmen, weil der ja alles Geld in seinen Kompromat generieren Sicherheitsapparat steckt, natürlich noch verstärkt wird. Und dummerweise, es sind halt, naja, so irgendwie aus dem Untergrund agieren, ist nicht so einfach, gibt es halt ein paar Verletzte dabei, immerhin keine Toten. Und es zwingt mich natürlich dazu, halt irgendwie mich davon zu distanzieren, weil eigentlich wollen wir zwar eine radikale meditante Bewegung sein, aber halt eben nicht Menschen verletzen. Und deswegen muss ich mich da halt so ein bisschen halbherzig bedauernd distanzieren. Aber die Schuld daran hat natürlich eigentlich El Fefe, weil der ist natürlich schuld an dieser Radikalisierung, weil er die Leute in den Untergrund getrieben hat und das Land halt zugunsten seiner Sicherheitsapparatus ausbluten lässt. Also El Fefe, du bist schuld an all dem.
Ja, das trifft sich ja prächtig mit dem Anschlag auf die Industriellen, weil die waren kurz davor, mir untreu zu werden, diese Scheiße. Die wollten nicht einsehen, dass sie mir Steuern zahlen müssen, damit unser Staat seine Sicherheitsinfrastruktur bezahlen kann. Die Nachhaltigkeit ist an der Stelle wichtig, deswegen verschärfe ich auch mal die Geldwäsche-Gesetze, damit ich ein bisschen einen Hebel gegen die in der Hand habe und erzähle dem Volk ein Trauermärchen von Produktfälschern und armen alten Omas, die an gefälschten Medikamenten starben.
Ja, jetzt wird die Sache langsam so ein bisschen unangenehm. Die echte Griff bombt die Börse weg. Dabei kommen 22 Menschen ums Leben, darunter auch normale Angestellte und Technikern. Meine FAD, das erzielt sich umgehend, aber niemand hört ihr so richtig zu, weil er ist der größte Terroranschlag in der Geschichte des Landes, erfolgreicher. Die echte Griff prangert in dem Bekennerschreiben die Bankster an und erklärt, dass jetzt kein Kapitalist von nun an mehr sicher ist. Ich fange dann langsam vorsichtig an, mich nach Exiloptionen im Ausland umzusehen, weil mir einigermaßen klar ist, was jetzt wohl kommen wird. Die Frage ist nur, was Fefe als nächstes tut.
Mir gehen langsam ein paar Verschwörungstheoretiker auf den Sack. Die fangen nämlich an, auf hohe Insider-Trading-Niveaus direkt vor dem Börsensturz hinzuweisen, als hätte jemand den Angriff kommen sehen. Und da hat noch jemand schnell ein paar Milliarden mitgemacht. Ich habe ja keine Ahnung, wie das gewesen sein könnte. Das ist natürlich völlig abenteuerlich absurd, abstrus. Da kann ich mich nicht direkt darauf antworten, sonst erhebe ich das ja noch im Niveau. Also lasse ich meine Dienste die Verschwörungstheorie infiltrieren und Theorien über orbitale Gehirnwäschekontrollleser verbreiten und das Strahlen. Genau, dass der Polizeirevier-Terroranschlag dingt, das war ganz am Anfang so ein Inside-Job. Und die Mondlandung war natürlich gefaked und Elvis lebt und so weiter und so fort. Und keiner glaubt denen mehr irgendwas. Ich habe meine Schäfchen im trockenen Einglück, dass meine Appelinfrastruktur so gut ausgebaut war. Das hätte auch uns auch gehen können mit der Börse. Politisch gesehen ist aber an der Zeit den Einsatz, die Armee im Inneren zu fordern, also zumindest in die Diskussion zu bringen und das Abschießen von gekaperten Passagierflugzeugen. Denn man muss immer auch ein paar völlig viel zu weit greifende Forderungen stellen, damit man, wenn man sich in der Mitte trifft, mit einem nach den Spielregeln spielenden Parlament, dann trifft man sich an der Mitte. Und die Mitte soll natürlich da sein, wo ich eigentlich hin wollte. Deswegen fordere ich nicht das, was ich haben will, sondern ich fordere das Doppelte dessen, was ich haben will, und treffe mich dann in der Mitte und habe alles gekriegt. So auch dieses Mal. Naja, das höchste Gericht widerspricht mir bei den Flugzeugabschussplänen. Das war ja vorherzusehen, aber das macht mir nichts. Denn ich kann mich jetzt in der Presse feiern lassen, in der konservativen Presse zumindest als jemand, der im Kampf gegen den Terror keine Schwäche zeigt.
Naja, man sieht schon, El Fefe ist jetzt irgendwie der neue starke Mann und wird halt ja doch zunehmend unangenehm. Und meine freien radikalen Demokratiefrunde zerlegen sich leider so ein bisschen in internen Debatten über den Sinn von Gewalt und was für Aussichten es noch so gibt und so. Und dann spaltet sich halt ein Militant-Aflügel ab. So, also zum größten Teil halt aus den Leuten, die halt an den Untergrund gegangen sind. Ein paar von den Leuten aus dem Untergrund und ein paar Leuten, die auch irgendwie einfach nicht mehr können, setzen sich mit mir zusammen halt ins Exil ab. Zum Glück gibt uns irgendwie das Land Neutralien ein politisches Asyl, weil sie sehen, dass wir halt politische Freiheitskämpfer sind und keine Terroristen. Und die Militanten, die halt da bleiben, die suchen halt den Kontakt zur echten Griff, die sie ganz herzlich willkommen heißt. Es gibt dann halt nur so eine Reihe von komischen Unfällen beim Bombenbauen, die halt dann alle der echten Griff zugeordnet werden. Und doberweise kommen halt da nur so meine Ex-Freunde aus dem FAD dabei ums Leben, die ja irgendwie dann sich immer beim Bombenbasteln vertan haben, aber keine Leute von der echten Griff, von denen bis heute niemand so richtig weiß, wer es eigentlich ist.
Ja, das kann ja schon mal passieren. Aber das ist natürlich doof für mich, denn ich war ja noch gar nicht Präsident. So geht das aber nicht. Ich hatte ja noch Pläne hier. Deswegen lasse ich mal eben von ausländischen Kommunisten einen Anschlag aus Parlament durchführen, schiebe ihnen der echten Griff in die Schuhe und lasse mich mit den eilig durchgewunkenen Notstandsgesetzen zum Präsidenten machen. Nicht auf Lebenszeit, das soll ja schon noch so ein bisschen demokratisch aussehen, sondern nur bis die Krise vorbei ist.
So, jetzt wissen wir, wie El Fefe zum Diktator von Absurdistan wurde. In der Folge 11 kann man dann nachhören, wie ich ihn gestürzt habe.
Tja, aber da hatte ich meine Schäfchen am trockenen insofern.
Na gut, ja. Ja, dann sind wir soweit durch für heute. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Wie immer gibt es da einen Flatter-Button. Und ansonsten noch der Hinweis beim Kongress, gibt es von uns wieder die Fnaut News Show. Für die Leute, die nicht zum Kongress kommen können, wird es auf jeden Fall einen Stream geben. Der wird bestimmt sehr lustig. Und wir werden dann auch mal vielleicht am Ende der Show auch mal ein bisschen was dazu erzählen, wie viele Leute eigentlich Alternativlos zu hören. Und ansonsten vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.